what is up people it's july 15th
h3 after dark
we're here baby
[Applause]
now what's the what's the vibe today ela
sexy librarian
because you about to make me act up girl
um right after you get me that book on
uh biology first minute and i got a
oh i just said a book about i'm just
i said girl um you better get me a book
about biology and then i'll do something
to you when i learn in that book
what it is that i can do
but what's the vibes is it sexy
librarian or something else
no but you look like [ __ ] hot
you look good
you got new glasses
oh okay yeah i've never seen you wear
those before yeah do you like it's a
little bit of a library vibe
yeah
i think they look great there's a touch
of library in there yeah but it's all
about because you got like a blazer
kind of laser well it is just a fun
blazer
but yeah i like the glasses a lot they
look great okay thank you yeah you look
awesome thank you anything like you
because i love you uh thank you to
hellofresh for sponsoring us today
now everybody back here is wearing a
hawaiian shirt i didn't get that but we
didn't get the memo i showed up i was
like are you guys pranking me what's up
with the hawaiian shirts nobody told me
anything about it you don't read the top
of the week emails
uh
what what zx started them yesterday
there's the email
[Music]
no there's no emails
it's just i have hawaiian shirts that i
would have liked to wear
right every single one of these guys is
in a hawaiian shirt
to be fair i wear them every day
so everyone's just kind of copying me
right now but i'm here for it i love it
we are blessing with the hawaiian shirts
today now i'll say zach you have the
leaves there is a hawaiian shirt
yeah yours is the least hawaiian shirt
this has been a pretty hot topic yeah
this is kind of what kicked all this off
there was a heated debate going on and
what does and doesn't qualify as a
hawaiian shirt
not definitely
disagree with it
that's it that's like a camp shirt it's
a button up
yeah no dude hawaiian shirts is like
you're gonna need to have the palm trees
and [ __ ] thank you yeah quiet now dan
you're quiet now minded you're so
you guys heard it's narrow-minded like
and it's just kind of like corny exactly
yeah this isn't corny
no
this isn't a corny shirt it's pretty
cool no it's it's corny
bro okay zach listen
it's not about corny okay she look if
you google hawaiian shirt no i just
threw that in there but
yeah like
there's always like leaves or palm trees
or birds look at this do you see any ac
dc rock and roll shirts look i wear
those flowers okay i'm i'm gonna um i'm
the kingdom of hawaiian shirts so i feel
that this is a hawaiian shirt it's not
it is though
it is the the definition nobody would
ever say that right the definitions that
we were working with yesterday were um i
have it right here oh you do and i'll
tell you why it's wrong a collared and
buttoned dress shirt usually short
sleeve and made from printed fabric
that's it that's it that's it
okay that is wrong
because you could have a dress shirt
that fits wrong
a loose brightly patterned hawaiian
shirt
aloha shirt [ __ ] ain't nobody
staying aloha exactly logical argument
a hawaiian shirt aloha shirt an aloha
shirt is a hawaiian shirt i wear this
there's nothing aloha about that shirt
this is my cruiserwear ethan this is
cruiserweight oh here we go the
definition that i have settled on myself
and if anybody would like to join me
over here it's if the shirt
makes sense on a plane to hawaii okay
thank you olivia you brought a
three-quarter shirt right well that's
the thing that shirt makes sense on a on
a plane ride to hawaii yeah i would
agree and look you rolled it up it
looked like i rolled it up yeah this is
obviously part of the life it's fine
like i don't know where you got that
definition from but it's obvious from
the most reputable source from throats
on wikipedia i mean this definition is
so stupid it's like yeah i believe it
they almost always have buttons it's
like really what it doesn't have a
button this is the wikipedia page
listen
let's just do a poll right out the gate
because i'm sorry but y'all trying to
tell me zack's wearing a hawaiian shirt
is just ridiculous i don't know if dan
should do this poll though now that's a
hawaiian channel
ian got the memo yeah ian
he did your homework yeah dude you're
chilling bro aloha dog
what about me i'm the king of hawaiian
churches yeah you're aloha bro yeah
well guess what there are no tigers in
hawaii that's right oh i just trapped
you that's right thank you daddy i see
trees or something but it doesn't have
to be in hawaii it's just got aloha
vibes definitely definition
no ethan's right okay i have an argument
a majority of these bands played in
hawaii don't give a [ __ ] okay
um
i had to shave let's see
oh yeah because i want to be like magnum
pi look how good cam
actually i didn't hear him either all
right
i said um i shaved a mustache to
compensate to be like magnum pi and zack
said i look like i i [ __ ] today
yeah you do look like you look good now
cam i'm not sure that's a hawaiian shirt
either that's that's why i shaved my
mustache should be like magnum pi
because i don't feel like
has a real hawaiian shirt wait so zach
brought two shirts so far that are both
not great zach did you bring more than
two i brought four
lena took mine my mine was a hawaiian
lena's wearing mine right now that's a
hawaiian shirt yeah alina's is hawaiian
oh yeah sure and lena looks beautiful
yeah you look like the uh
you look like the all-star employee at
trader joe's lina
employee of the month
sholina
i was like oh damn oh yeah totally
trader joe's vibes today
okay listen listen let's just do a poll
and sam
sam let's see that
oh you're muted they're not hawaiian but
dope
this one's it's so artsy yeah that one's
sick
hey whose shirt is that this is one of
zach guess what it's not hawaiian though
it doesn't matter you like button up
hawaiian okay crazy wacky let's just say
i like wacky shirts but you have
hawaiian shirts but you left all of them
at home because i'm proving a point i'm
proving a point today i would argue like
the fabric is what makes it a hawaiian
shirt or not
like the how
lightweight it is
i agree
zach i hate to break with you but you're
the shirt you're wearing is not that
wacky it's just a button-up shirt it's
just it's just corny like you said it's
okay let's do a poll is zach wearing a
hawaiian shirt i mean because zach well
obviously you're swaying the audience
here it's gonna be a hard no why zach
agrees with you sam agrees with you i i
agree with him too yeah that's all that
matters is dan's
wearing a hawaiian shirt
i do agree that dan's approval is very
important i'm surprised
yeah he's way off i'm surprised
that we're not aligned
it's true we're usually energetically
aligned but look a hawaiian shirt could
also be classified as something you'd
wear on vacation not necessarily to
hawaii but you know loungewear
why not you're just standing the
definition dude that's just a shirt
is that yeah
yeah oh yeah hawaiian shirt is just a
shirt you could wear on vacation um
listen i'm voting a big [ __ ] juicy no
on this yeah
i don't give a [ __ ] vote whatever you
want people don't care what i have to
say
people don't [ __ ] vote i'm surprised
the polls getting so many yeses wait i
can't see the result
uh well it's
the yes is a resounding win it's like 90
yes no that's no it's not it's what
uh 38 yes 62 no i'll take that 38 thank
you so much talking to me guys the
hawaiian shirt is a very easy to define
at first sight this is really something
it's really it makes sense why this
country is the way it is
[Laughter]
yeah and then and can you do a poll was
the election stolen
the same ratio
there's one other person whose input we
probably need on this
okay
i know where this is going
okay
now that's a hawaiian shirt aloha my dog
there you go aloha brother he's
connecting his audio standby standby
aloha dude
hawaiian friday
gabe can i ask you a question buddy
yeah
sho can you show him zach's shirt
do we have the technology
yeah is that a hawaiian shirt that
zack's wearing or no
i can't say yes but with words
right aloha does words and aloha with
words right
what's popping today what where are you
what's behind you
patio buddy
by the way you were instagram live
yesterday and i saw you chatting up some
people were just like the [ __ ] baby oh
and i tried to request to go live but i
guess you didn't see it
i don't see it it's just so many people
and the music is so loud
yeah yeah
anyway happy friday
happy friday
how's the strip club
the strip club is great actually
yesterday i was at print street out the
arts district with my man um
my man frank
so did you get a did you get a private
dance
nah no dance this weekend oh just a
pizza okay oh you got pizza and enjoyed
the size oh that's even better
do you make it rain when you watch
strippers
or oh yeah definitely yeah
sometimes that's forest
sometimes it's funny
yeah what does that mean
i like they want me to dance okay and
they're trying to push it some more and
it makes it rain
oh
but like you know what i mean like with
the money you make it rain with them oh
yeah yeah yeah
yeah cool man it's awesome
[ __ ] yeah
[Music]
[ __ ] baby [ __ ]
more like
a wolf right yeah is the wolf is not
the is the wolf really
yeah maybe that's not the vibe huh
what are you doing this weekend any fun
plans or what well we're promoting this
video
with me and my buddy nick nick it's
called blockbuster
go check out the video blockbuster
nickname
i'm the person in the cow head oh can i
watch it right now let me pull it up
sure sure what is it it's like a music
video
how's it going
blockbuster blockbuster by nick nick
yeah yeah all right let's check it out
let's see what's up
blockbuster nick nick the thumbnail is
just like yeah you see that it's a short
the second one oh okay okay let's go
okay let's put it on the map dude 76
views we're about to blow this up
blow this up [ __ ] [ __ ]
ow help
2180k let's freaking go a short film by
nick nick in indiana who's indiana
it's one of it's one of the um
like tick tock stars
okay and how come you're not credited in
the intro he's just in it
i'm just in it okay just to help
just to help with the video and my um
they probably should they should
probably put you in the title because i
think you probably have the most
celebrity power i'm just saying it
should be featuring white claw gabe
right yeah mm-hmm
that would
you know what i mean it's not up to me
yeah it's not happening
baby whoever produced the video well
let's take a quick look he's in the end
yeah oh he get it okay good
let's see
featuring mikaya
blockbuster
okay
oh yeah this is your nephew right
yeah
let's go
[Music]
okay [ __ ] you come on
hawaiian shirt buzz
okay okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
he's like a pizza delivery boy with
flair
who's the girl
it's indiana
okay it's pretty fire yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
damn they're about to turn up does he
does he get her in the end is that how
it ends let's skip to them not yet
second typical friday night or something
yo so check it out nick nick blockbuster
featuring white claw gabe
nice wait wait wait where were you i
want to see europe cameo in it oh you
didn't
you haven't reached that part yet
it's at the very end
yeah kind of like in the end
it's after the end credit okay
249. oh thank you
2
49 let's see that white clock gave cameo
with me with my partner um ryan action
one of my videos
we call him ashley dang bro that's an
interesting angle you're eating the
pizza it's like at a yeah
it's like at a slight angle it's
interesting
nice bro congratulations man
sounds good it actually does sound
really good congratulate nick nick for
us yeah
hey will you send a message to nick for
me
tell them pissing my ass [ __ ]
ouchy ouchy
all right buddy well that's
congratulations that that that's
actually a bop yeah wow
take care buddy nice hawaiian friday
happy hawaiian friday man we love
hawaiian friday
gabe got it friday man's wearing a
hawaiian shirt nobody he read the email
i get no [ __ ] emails why aren't you
on this chain ethan
to email you embarrass me
well according to you guys this is a
hawaiian yeah that wasn't no no no but
you're definitely no no it has to be a
button up that's not a button what's
this no that's not all the way out yeah
really yeah that's a polo
it's like it's just a camp shirt then
yes
[ __ ] you guys you know what you guys
are like um you and zach are like it's
just a shirt with buttons you're like
these congress people who pretend like
they don't know what an abortion is you
know they go
you've seen that right those videos yeah
of course i've seen it yeah that's you
right now oh he's gonna make it
political either do you want to make a
political new that we can all do next
friday yeah it's not just us i'll wear
hawaiian shirts all of us but do we want
to move on from hawaii something else
fighting so much about it right i will
skip i will be wearing a hawaiian shirts
are very dividing
[Music]
um sure yeah i'm down i'm down all right
we'll talk about it well gabe listen
you got the assignment right man and
that's all that matters
yeah
yeah baby [ __ ] my [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
all right love you buddy thanks
have a good week guys friday baby [ __ ]
happy friday [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] baby oh
ouchie
white claw gabe everybody wow oh wow
always uh always always the partners
yeah white club gabe you can find him on
cameo and everywhere before
we move on eli you you made this shirt
yes
how would you classify this
camp shirt there you go not hawaiian but
if it's dan's definition it has which is
why i'm confused exactly it's not a
hawaiian shirt look at look at what i
just put on screen yeah look at who made
it who made it who wrote that
who wrote that what do you mean who
wrote that i don't know who wrote it
what do you mean what website is it on
oh it's on ebay
ebay so it's just some random idiot
it's a hawaiian
twine
sorry the yeses have been climbing by
the way we're up to 45 there we go are
you serious yes
shout out
we're digging ourselves out of this hole
okay if you all say so i don't know some
people say it's a bull the fact that
then
is strongly believing in that makes me
question myself well i will admit to
that whoa he's not right on this ela
it's not a hawaiian shirt man
all right let's move on somebody asked
for oh you want to stop my account
update session somebody wants what now
housewives update oh yeah we have all
right at the top you want to do
housewives already we don't have to do a
couple things i want to talk about yeah
we'll do it a little bit later
housewives updates are full yeah bro jen
shaw got she got like 15 years in jail
dude well we don't we don't know yet but
she pleaded guilty she pleaded guilty
yeah which is all anyway we'll get into
that yeah first thing i want to talk
about here is um
well we have actually a great show here
let me tell you guys what we got coming
up we'll talk about all this teddy fresh
controversy first
um if you don't know about it i'll tell
you all about it and we got we're having
a howie mandel what are we going to do
about it competition
we green screen howie going my friend
neil bent over and this happened what do
we do about it and so by the way i had
one of james charles and his giant
nipples many of you guys probably saw
because they had 12 million views on
tick tock and this morning they erased
the mother they erased my [ __ ] dude
damn that's horrible it had 12 million
views that's horrible everybody was
loving it you know why it was removed it
says hateful behavior i'm sorry
what
does anyone have
does anyone have a backup we can show
there are people at home
but yeah it had 1.7 million likes dude
yeah that's why that's like mega viral
moment i was having a viral moment
that's what i'm saying i don't really
[ __ ] with tick tock that heavy because
it seems like half of the [ __ ] i make is
somebody removed
you know what rules you sons of [ __ ]
that's how i feel right now
what rules you sons of [ __ ]
yeah here here this is it 12 million
views just tweeted did somebody know is
this code related and if it is what do
we do about it
ow
now i don't know what's hateful about
that but it was up for like
two days 12 million views
everyone was having fun
utter carelessness of the twitter
organization
[ __ ] you up yours tick tock
what rules you sons of [ __ ]
200 donation y'all are out of control
what happy friday i made a hairline
ranking site to crown and official
hairline king and a fair dim well that's
awesome fair democratic process is that
a real website hairline hierarchy that's
such a good name
well you know i'm number one i mean who
could beat me
yeah
actually uh
i saw a contender um just yesterday uh
ally
sent me a screenshot from um 90 day
fiance there's a
new season of it i guess and she was
watching it and there's somebody on the
show that might give you a room for your
money oh yeah okay let's take a look
airline hierarchy oh [ __ ] this is a real
website
the kings queens
and nb overlords of hairline world what
is nb non-binary overlapping oh okay i
don't really trust this website
okay it's unvetted yeah because
with wordpress when you make like votes
and stuff they take the ip
and if the
the website is not built correctly that
ip can be public
so don't
we'll vet your website but i like where
your head's at this could be a big thing
this could this would go a long way
yeah that hit that doesn't look natural
there's something going on there
there's definitely something going on
here
i mean
it's
it is if that's real then he's a
hairline [ __ ] god
he's alexander the great of hairlines it
had the appearance of a thick mat of
hair right
it looks like he has veneers on too so
he's just all
jacked up with the
flashy stuff interesting
no but this is all natural dan oh
natural so we're going to do the how so
we have the howie mandel meme
competition um which we
sell out a bat signal to everyone at
home exciting because i do i do not want
to let this howie mandel meme die i'm
determined for this to live forever the
man posted a prolapse anus
we can't forget about this yeah what do
we do about it and the fact that howie
mandel makes it even better but go ahead
are we talking about it or is it not yet
you're just kind of like well
not yet not yet okay
i was just gonna say i've been avoiding
watching it yeah so ela has not looked
at the prolapse yet and we're gonna make
you
live react to the prolapse you posted
for people at home i really feel like
it's gonna get stuck in my head and i'll
never forget the image it just looks
like a sock that's like halfway inside
out no
i could see it like it's gonna happen to
me once i watch it i think i have like a
weird weird feeling inside oh
i hope not i'll prolapse for you if you
give
whatever you want girl
i can see it clearly in my head i don't
know about you guys but i could just
imagine it perfectly right now yeah the
gray ring yeah
the shade of the pink and then the
halfway inside-out sock yeah yeah that
was weird pretty crazy
um and then our main segment is going to
be
you guys maybe have heard about the
dolly image generator so this is a
advanced ai it's in beta stage and then
they made the dolly 2 which is so
insanely advanced
it is going to blow everyone's mind and
the question is as you guys know cam is
the photoshop
expert here
man versus machine who's gonna make a
better
response to our prompts i'm sorry day
cam is probably the closest to a machine
yes yeah
i think cameron cameron's not giving
himself a lot of credit but i actually
think he's got a good shot we were
playing around with it
uh on wednesday on wednesday after this
and like it's really amazing sometimes
it hit hard and sometimes it misses
it really missed the mark on that one so
i don't know cameron i think my whole
life with that one good i don't want to
work against the machine i want to work
with the machine i mean
we'll get more into it later but it has
its faults and i i feel like i could
perfect the images that it makes this is
a john henry versus the steam drill type
scenario here okay this is life or death
you guys are enemies okay for now okay
i'm sorry dave in the spirit of the
competition you're going down
i'm sorry come on
i'm afraid i can't do that so let's
start at the top because
there's this teddy fresh controversy
that's annoying the [ __ ] out of me
[Music]
um
this has been popping up
for a few months
uh yeah on and off
and well here's the post that was going
big on our subreddit yesterday now first
of all what's so sus about this how many
awards did this get who's giving awards
on like a hate post like i saw it after
three hours and it had like 20 awards
and my what my theory is is that
this is being fueled by
trisha stans
and keemstar and possibly cav cav
you know
and actually have evidence for all that
stuff which is pretty interesting nine
awards i mean what the [ __ ] who's paying
for this [ __ ]
who's naturally on our website who's
like i'm gonna pay reddit because i
[ __ ] love this post this is what's up
it says these employees anonymously
spoke up for a reason i think it's fair
people see this mods are taking anything
with glass door in the title
by the way it's not like we don't have
like a block on the word i know that
cracked me up like it's like a slur
yeah totally
as i was making this the tf class door
link stopped working on all my devices
what
it's like riddled with conspiracy theory
you know what i mean it's just written
like in a [ __ ] up way where it's like
they're taking down everything i have to
write in code it's working
like we control the glass door website
yeah exactly it's all conspiracy
and what basically you find on glassdoor
is
a bunch of really bad reviews about the
working conditions at teddy fresh
and what's really weird about these
reviews okay first the first thing you
need to tell you about glassdoor is that
anybody can write a review there
about anything of any position of any
time they could say anything they want
there's no moderation there's no even
opportunity for the company to respond
there's literally no
oversight at all
i could go to nike right now and be like
yo i worked here as a shoot technician
and uh
you know i'm just saying slap me yeah
every day slam me right across the face
they put baby foreskin in the uh
in the sole of the shoes that's what
makes them so comfy
you can write that action
what's really interesting about it
is that teddy fresh has been in business
for five long [ __ ] years
and all these reviews started springing
up six months ago
five years nothing there and then all of
a sudden six months ago
it was like all at once like 15 [ __ ]
negative reviews
and
some of them say [ __ ] like uh i
overheard one of the owners saying
i like to manage my team like lord of
the flies yeah
yeah i remember somebody mentioning that
in the comments
do i manage you guys like lord of the
flies at all or maybe a little bit eh
is anyone dead on the floor at the end
of the day not really nope there's no
dead piggy sincerely you guys are
yeah i know that was upsetting
it's insane but i i don't know i mean
like maybe maybe there's a couple that
are real there and it obviously it
really is sad to see and it i mean i'm i
i take it very seriously and
i do believe that we're improving the
company all the time and constantly
working on it and constantly trying to
make sure
it's a really good environment for our
employees we try to make everyone feel
like they're
they're valued because we really do
value everybody that works for us it's i
mean
it's just like
it's so important to us and i think that
our environment is really positive i
don't think it's toxic
i mean i i'm there like all the time
i i get along great with everybody i
feel like we all collaborate it's like
it's a fun place to work at
so
i don't know i mean maybe a couple of
those are real and it's sad and i do
take it seriously and i will make sure
that if there is valid criticism in
there we take it into
consideration and we're accountable
but like something there also doesn't
make sense with the amount of the
reviews and stuff like you said with the
lord of the flies
yeah comment or
i don't know well what's okay like
like you said i'm willing to concede
that maybe one or two of them is real i
don't know i have no way of knowing i
mean they never did the website never
reached out to us to confirm
hey this is this person really
from that position at your company that
never happened so i have no idea
but the thing is when you're working in
a job for five years people come and go
and every breakup isn't always amicable
and some people i'll be honest some
people are shitty employees and they
suck and you need to fire them that's
just reality of owning a [ __ ]
business and sometimes they're pissed
off because whatever i don't know but
the truth is i don't know what's real
and what's not i mean obviously people
are going to be bitter when they get
fired some people but the majority of
those are just total [ __ ] and like i
just hate that people keep bringing this
up and parading it around and i see
people do stuff where they'll like
they'll find one clip of something i
said years ago where i'm like oh ela's a
bad hard ass and she rolls with the iron
fist something like i'm saying facetious
i know and i don't even know like that
once
all these are true i don't even know
what you meant when you said that it was
so long ago but it's actually like
nothing to do with how i work with
people at teddy fresh like
i don't know it was probably mostly a
joke and like
i remembered that but it was so long ago
and it wasn't like anything serious and
no i don't
i no i'm not like that so i don't know
well you'll be relieved to hear that
sarah mentz says she's worked at tf for
45 years and she has good thing she says
it's great
yeah
but what i'll say is like
um i mean we work teddy fresh is right
next door we all are here together and
we work with these guys
you know lena worked for teddy fresh for
a year zack's girlfriend chantel works
at teddy fresh
it's not like dude we're not [ __ ]
turning people into horse glue over
there it's like a good working condition
i'm jealous they're always having a
party over there they got arcade games
always a good time over there every time
i walk in karaoke yeah
yeah utopian work environment ping pong
ping pong how can we go so utopia
there's ping pong yeah why don't we have
a ping pong table over here table get a
ping pong table we got mortal kombat
you're approving that purchase i have
beef with that honestly
i work i worked at a uh office with a
ping pong table and that [ __ ] is so
annoying
i was trying to work and all day
okay i hate to be the hater but
i don't know interesting maybe maybe
i'll make you have a point there and
keep it to after hours
by the way this [ __ ] always this [ __ ]
always comes up it's just so [ __ ] up
and it's so obvious to me
that it's all bad faith like we worked
so hard specifically ela to build this
company and do it the right way
and i feel like there's really nothing
bad you can say or criticize teddy fresh
for we've done everything the right way
we've done it like ourselves from the
beginning
and you know
people are always looking for a reason
to tear it down they're always looking
for reason to tear it down like my
myself and this show there's plenty of
[ __ ] you can [ __ ] uh criticize me for
you can make a billion exposed videos i
mean but teddy fresh is not like that
it's like clean and wholesome
and we did it right you know what i mean
it's just not a controversial [ __ ]
company it's just not
and uh every time something happens like
we're doing this big 50 sale
because we want everyone to have the
opportunity to get some [ __ ]
at an affordable price because the world
is [ __ ] right now
and it's like it always happens around
that like a big collab or sometimes we
announce something or whatever it is it
always pops up like did you know that
they're like the worst [ __ ] employees
ever right um and it's just and you know
it's just [ __ ] up and i even see fans
people of teddy fresh who are like man
it sucks to see that uh they're horrible
employees and it's like you see me
interacting with my employees
[ __ ] 12 hours a week you know
i love these guys they're a family
i mean i
don't even think of them as employees
family stop
oh yeah haters were saying that we stole
the money when we [ __ ] raised like a
hundred thousand dollars for charity
there's just like it doesn't matter what
we do we always try to do the best thing
we
you know it's like and every time we
fire someone we give like way over the
industry standard of severance we we
give really good savings
whenever we have to listen really good
conditions too like we started this
um friday they only work until one
because it's like
friday summer we just want to let
everybody have some more free time
um everybody gets like free clothing all
the time you know it's just like little
things i don't feel like i need to say
it i don't want to like brag about what
we do to make it a nice place but it
really is a nice place to work at and
like i'm there all the time and we all
love each other and we have a great
environment there so it's not like what
it's being portrayed to be and it just
sucks to see it because
it's really far from the truth i mean
and i'll say we've gone out of our way
that like every employee is paid over
the industry standard
we have as good as benefits as we can
offer which is like pension health care
dental vision
we have um
um i mean we consult with hr people too
all the time if there is anything it's
not like um
we're just winging it over there and
i don't know
we do everything by the book it's not oh
yeah paid time off you apparently that's
crazy to me that people don't even get
paid time off but yeah what i don't know
what it is like two weeks or something
over there i don't know somebody in the
chat is chiming and they said they
worked at teddy fresh and neil was
amazing um someone in chat yeah he's
assertive and strong but ethan would
come in and constantly rip ass
it's just not right
that's just not true see that's that's
the kind of thing you'll read on uh
last door
it's actually nicer than most the ship
right in there
but actually you know so and it's like
anyone else that's trying to run a
company doesn't have to deal with this
kind of [ __ ] you know but it's like
because of who we are
everybody's taking shots and there's so
many people that hate me and i'll i have
actually some really interesting
receipts
um
like look at this this is a keemstar
okay
from
two weeks ago
on a podcast
with you know 150 000 views
talking about this before it ever became
a thing right
i mean it's been a thing but like a
recent thing where it got posted and got
like a billion uh upvotes and rewards
but listen to keemstar talk about this
okay nathan's wife because i think she
owns teddy fresh or freddy fresh or
whatever the [ __ ] it is ready fresh but
you know what that's called that that's
he says that every time he brings
someone else a b or whatever is that his
name is that his name yeah yeah you know
it's funny he acts like he doesn't know
anything about us and then in this
interview he exposed himself so much
like he knows every [ __ ] little thing
it's crazy like he's such a fan bro
such fan behavior you gotta get your
employees under control because they hit
me up on instagram non-stop dude you
need stronger andy yeah
every they're hitting him up all the
[ __ ] time yeah
he's obviously he's lying okay
the type of people that work at teddy
fresh don't know who keems they don't
know the [ __ ] they're not these are
fashion people they're industry people
they're not in the youtube no they don't
know who came
nobody knows who you are your channel's
[ __ ] dead bro terrorist like sorry
but that [ __ ] that that age of people
going to do with [ __ ] is like uh ancient
history anyway nobody's buying that
okay
yeah it's what i was like i'm telling
you and they're not happy they're very
upset like some of them not a lot
many complaints actually somebody linked
me this um
there's a place where you can uh you can
rate a place of employment
oh yeah yeah yeah i thought i thought he
was about to go like if they gave me a
legal doc that hasn't been released yet
i'm like what the [ __ ]
this you know i like some ordinary gamer
after like our whole beef we kind of
made up but i just don't know why he
keeps platforming keemstar to [ __ ]
lie and say [ __ ]
like this
uh
i don't know how you can continue to be
friends with someone like that i mean
he's the reason that ordinary gamer made
that video in the first place that he
had to erase and apologize for about me
and yet he still has him in his [ __ ]
makeshift bedroom
uh that looks like he just basically uh
it's weekend at middle school and uh
he's gonna play some like you know world
of warcraft all day after this and
[ __ ] jerk off into a sock and then go
take a nap to mute it to har
was that him trying to say he can't even
say his name i i'm not defending mudahar
um i don't think he should but
in his defense i guess i would say that
keemstar like if you make a video about
ethan he builds you up as best he can he
had him on the podcast after that you
know he
he'll build your career he'll take the
smallest channels possible but if you
talk about ethan he'll help you out
right right i know that but he was or
his channel was already doing pretty
well before all that
but whatever whatever but that was a
long time ago somewhere in a gamer has
his own thing and it's just [ __ ]
weird it's like bro you platforming this
guy who's been lying about me he's lying
here
and it's just [ __ ] up dude this guy is
just a piece of [ __ ] i thought he was
about to go like if they gave me a
little dark that hasn't been released
yet i'm like what the [ __ ]
this girl this girl was trying to leak
stuff and i told her i go don't like
you're going to get sued yeah
right yeah i love that keemstar is
worried about the employee
yeah right instead of trying to bash us
he's so worried basically what that
means is somebody trolled kim star and
sent him some made up [ __ ] and kim star
knows it so he was like yeah i can't i
can't run with this because it's
obviously made up but i can just allude
to it or right or
he's making it all up possible same
thing and he just wants to tell people
to go check out glassdoor which it's
likely a lot of those reviews are
written by him or his homies because
there's no [ __ ] oversight i go don't
like you're going to get sued like don't
don't do it like i had an opportunity to
really [ __ ] on you guys and i did not
take it yeah i put my petty beef aside
and was looking for the
the well-being and safety of one of your
accidents yeah this is him this is him
participating in the petty beef he's
crying is what abe calls the king slide
he's trying to get people to talk about
this to turn it into an issue without
actually having to report on something
that's not real i'm busted yeah you're a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] dude if it did
happen someone's probably like i have
some dirt on teddy fresh and they're
like and keem's like what do you got and
then they sent the picture of your bare
ass to him ah
that's prob people do that all the time
i love you yeah
yeah because he has been trying from the
beginning of teddy fresh he's always
been trying to find something about it
yeah and not just him yeah like there's
a community of like tricia stands who
ate my [ __ ] guts and this glass door
reviews are always posted there not
talking about her it's just not no it's
not hazardous
okay yeah
i'll say trish has nothing to do with it
but there's a community of psychos that
has nothing to do with her she doesn't
interact with them it's not her fault
i'm just saying that it's always posted
there
and people there are participating in
the same thing so it just became like a
[ __ ] ground for people to be like i
worked at teddy fresh and they treat us
like lord of the flies and i emailed
keemstar
like what evidence could they even have
you know what i mean if you're just an
employee of teddy fred what do you got
that's so damning that you can send
keemstar
right like what
what nothing nothing there's nothing if
it was something he definitely would
have shared it uh yeah
of course
this guy goes yeah has no limit to what
he'll do to try to ruin my life and
that's why i [ __ ] hate his
guts employees who want to really
[ __ ] [ __ ] on your company uh because
i knew you would sue them keemstar yeah
because we still people right and left
right like we still to this they never
suit anybody so what are you talking
about how many people have we stood we
have never sued anybody never if if we
would ever sue somebody it would be you
can start and you're still not sued yeah
so
death noodles took the mantle yeah
but i'm just saying like it's all such
[ __ ] dude it's such [ __ ]
[ __ ] and it's just sucks dude
you know it just breaks my heart that um
this thing that we've worked so hard for
and uh
mostly ila honestly
is just always under the microscope of
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] and i also have
other leads here
um we have evidence that bobby lee
uh was writing some of these reviews oh
my revenge for the mole thing
actually here's an ex photo leaving a
teddy fresh review on glassdoor keemstar
actually
ladies and gentlemen
um
oh yeah there's something interesting
here
apparently there was even a subreddit
called teddy fresh exposed that was made
four months ago i didn't even know about
this
um but this one it's like dude what are
you doing i actually went on the sub and
asked them to prove if they ever worked
at teddy fresh and nobody could give any
solid evidence that they did
they giving kev kev energy
also the mods were all new and their
accounts look like sock puppets i try to
go back to that sub but i can't find
anything it seems like it's been banned
or said private didn't you guys ever see
that i didn't even know about this you
never knew about it
too much wine sorry
um i just got my new teddy fresh and
found this
it's awesome
yeah they're actually slaves
did you see the comments on that below
hope you called the cops because it's
obviously not good did you did you
conclude ethan ila wouldn't hold it
together i would like responsibly as
well awesome
all right
why are you even on our subreddit i feel
like
well before before people jump down
their throat i feel like that might be a
joke click it and look at their profile
see what their comments are okay i feel
like that's real
i feel like it might be sarcasm i don't
i just want ethan to comment on this
i don't think it's real but we should
still wait for ethan to comment on this
send help thing i will never order tf
again that person is definitely joking i
don't know click it
yeah you'd be surprised bro
oh my god with reddit people i always
just assume the worst yeah cause i think
that they're all being me no matter what
i'm i'm gonna
give them a little bit of benefit i'm
trying to find the thread right now i'm
i'm on it i'm looking
oh yeah yeah yeah i i do have to say
chantal and i uh commute together to
work and you know always ask you how's
your day and she's always speaking very
positively about her job and she loves
it she's a part of a team
and she's nothing but the utmost respect
for her job and what she does and she
just enjoys every aspect of it
thank you i just want to throw that
thank you and we love her by the way
she's so good at her job yeah
here's the comment and then somebody
said never forget the backslash s my
friend and i said i just noticed but boy
people sure there you go well the
problem is they're joking
king queen the problem is there's people
on reddit if you go to these hate
subreddits they're leaving comments like
that it is
yeah they believe
it
somewhat believable but you know yeah
interacts with ourselves
yeah and it's like stuff's gonna happen
like this and we just
obviously it's like part of what we do
so that's fine and we're used to it but
it sucks when it actually gains like
traction on reddit and then gets like
thousands of votes and then
at that point we need to address it so
that's just why we're talking about it
it's like i
i understand that this stuff's gonna
happen so
i i don't want to seem like too much
like i don't know
we're being whiny or something it's like
it's fine this is gonna happen we're
we're on the internet this is what we do
well there was a big subset of people
that
you know
rightfully or not we're demanding some
sort of response to this so you're
addressing it you know
look at this title toxicity at its
finest
what
i mean what does that even say to you
like how [ __ ] bad is that if it was a
toxic environment don't you think that
you some of us would know that like that
bad
that bad
um
let's
see
yeah someone put a lot of time into
these
it's all about toxicity which is like
i don't know you know i'm sure there's
some criticisms for of i'm yeah of of
the way that we work on teddy fresh
since we're
like you know kind of we're new to this
and it's all a lot of learning but toxic
i don't know sinking ship
you know what i mean
how do you define that this is a sinking
shape like what yeah a sinking ship
that's
yeah it's just it's [ __ ] sucks it's
stupid
toxic
and like working for 13 year old mean
girls that is so not the case
there's no way it's all about the
leadership too which is weird bad
leadership toxic which is exactly you're
not a 13 year old mean girl
yeah exactly which is us
and you know what like first of all i
know it's not toxic there obviously it's
me so you can take it or leave it i'm
not
whatever but
if that's the biggest criticism
hey there's no abuse there's no like
harassment there's no there's no actual
like problems they all say that they
have a problem with me and that it's
toxic
so
take it for what it is i don't know
look at this this [ __ ] is crazy bro
depression and anxiety and the little
things keep you up at night right living
in a glass house with no friends and
friends are just fans that you never met
or care about tf employees are not in
the public eye like h3 so they're all
expendable and fragile eagles will keep
this company from ever becoming anything
but a merch brand for youtube fans this
has to be fake
so obviously you guys had potential to
be great but the culture you guys
decided unsealed your fate
yeah it's pretty yeah it's it's
yeah that is so you know what i mean
it's it's hurtful it sucks and the
website's so [ __ ] stupid there's
literally nothing you can even do about
it you can't contest it you can't they
don't verify employment there's
literally nothing to do about it
actually it sucks because it does affect
like when we're trying to recruit people
people do go to that website and really
[ __ ] sucks because they see all that
[ __ ]
there's nothing to do about it
do you guys remember rape my professor
back yesterday yeah is that still around
yes it is
they got rid of one of the features on
there which was the chili pepper
um
yeah dude that that website was
revolutionary i'd be so scared to be a
teacher with that [ __ ] because it's like
oh this be so painful that's what this
reminds me of because
not like when you would check that
you could always kind of like
see the ones it was like oh this person
failed hard in this class and they're
upset about it and they're just like
going scorched earth yeah right now to
try and [ __ ] over and over
and it's like just because you got an
easy a doesn't mean they're a good
teacher the whole thing is like right
not [ __ ] true
yeah people saying they regularly use it
yeah it's well
some people think it's essential yes
essentially it is yeah i used to have
that open while you're picking classes
at the same time
that came out right as i was finishing
school so i never really got the benefit
of using it
but it tripped me out when i saw that
dude
jordan peterson has a 4.5
rate my professor
no no way he's on there yeah but it's
all like he's retired it's all like
fanboys of his that are right in this
case
we live in a society
well let's see what he
says jordan peterson is a living legend
and an amazing human being quit speaking
this is bro this is from last month
yeah he hasn't taught a class in years
he's a living legend he is literally the
most educated person you will ever meet
literally become a joker literally
you sons of [ __ ]
you're the worst shut the [ __ ] up
one of the most genuine intelligent
people you ever meet
his course was definitely tough
i could truly say i learned something we
got to start leaving reviews for jordan
peterson i'm in pain ouchy
so i don't know and it sucks because you
know you just that's that's what it is
so there you go people demanding a
response from us
there you have it
okay i don't know what to say if you
don't believe it
there's nothing else i can really say
about it
you know
i know something to say
teddy fresh is currently 50 off
yeah
what i really wanted to just give a
quick plug to is that we're doing a
teddy fresh 50 off sale
because the world is ending
or feels like it anyway this whole
segment has actually just been an ad
gotcha i wish
i wish that was just genius marketing
teddy fresh is on sale everybody 50 off
the whole website that's right
the world is ending why not look good
that's right
you know it's hard out there folks
go
so look at you got the classic color
block you got the looney tunes color
block the reverse fleece color block
all kind of there's so many nice things
here guys that's all
right
thank you keem rick and morty stuff
um
eli klein original stuff point
more looney tune stuff these these
hoodies are really beautiful by the way
such a good deal on these
the paisley print all over
you know keep going down my dad wears tf
crew neck
in it
i don't know why
this i think this piece is so beautiful
i never understood why what happened
there were so many delays and deliveries
it released like after the winter so
unfortunately
yeah yeah
it is a nice cozy warm piece i'm not
gonna lie
but i just thought it was such a
beautiful looking striking piece but
that's up there
these floral hoodies are up there
this awesome sweaters up there
you know acid wash this sweater i mean
come on
hey
it's 50 off
let's go put your hands in the air it's
50 off 50
50. okay 50 hey
50
50
50
per cent oh okay
50 videos
14 pages
by the way this hoodie is dope as [ __ ]
too yeah it's gotta of course shipped to
the uk right yeah everywhere somebody
just asked in the chat everywhere
this hoodie is like unusually uh amazing
though i love the fabric of the hoodie
the watch came out so nice
you know
hey
put your hands in the air
okay let's go
this is uh looney tunes hoodie
this jacket is sick
50 50
50. this one is dope i saw oliver tree
wearing this oh really
cool
yeah awesome
more hawaiian than zach's shirt
[Music]
so you know there's a ton of really cool
stuff if y'all wanna
head on over there
okay let's go
it's all 50 off this piece again this is
another banger that
i'm surprised there's any of these left
[Music]
it's so nice
houndstooth is that what you call it
oh and this one too this one is a
this one's super nice it's a um thermal
aligned thermal lined bro it's so sick
check this
out
the inside's thermal lining
very nice yes sir finney present off
let's do it
[Music]
okay let's go yeah there's so much nice
stuff so check it out
oh and then this sweater too this yeah
this sweater is insane
oh this one's sold out but i guess the
blue one's still there do you guys have
any hawaiian shirts on there any
did that
hawaiian and casual shirt let's go
20th century classic rock hawaiian sorry
but those are contradictory
put a pineapple on there you know
i will say that the new camp shirt uh
you guys just put out the gentle thrills
one yeah hands down one of my favorite
shirts i love it
yeah the i spoke when i got it the fit
the feel the material i mean it's
comfortable i love it awesome thanks bro
so that's what that is so
if you don't think that our employees
are slaves
then have a good time over at teddy
fresh 50 percent off look good while the
world ends thank you let's go okay
let's do it somebody donated 50 bucks
said it's currently winner in australia
cold weather items that got delayed are
perfect for all the aussie homies
getting chilly definitely sending thanks
to my aussie friends so there you go
yeah unfortunately the shipping is
insane but uh maybe the 50 will uh make
up for soften that blow the shipping
prices are so nuts lately man
and they've just gotten more expensive
because all the inflation and gas prices
it's not it's a crazy time to try to run
a business yeah prices continuously
are just going up and up it's crazy well
it's crazy prices go up and then
people's money is worth less
and it's like it's getting harder and
harder to sell [ __ ] but somehow there's
still inflation
how's that it doesn't make any sense
it's like it's getting harder to sell
[ __ ] getting harder to buy stuff and yet
there's still massive inflation
it doesn't make sense go to joe
3 0
3
3 0.
there it is huh so there you go all
right
let's get on to something fun now um
we're actually already an hour into the
show holy [ __ ] balls
maybe we can do a little
something before going into
another ad
or our actual ad
um
any quick goofs or anything
yeah i'm looking to see what would be a
fun you know what guys want to do the
heimlich
are you hey elena did you practice the
heimlich
yeah so
we told us anecdote about hey a.b almost
died choking on steak at sizzler
and it's not the first time it's
happened to you and i said well lena you
better learn how to do the heimlich
because this [ __ ] gonna choke
again yeah and you better be ready next
time because everyone else was just
watching you sucked it up it's very
scary
so lena did you
did you how did you study to prepare for
this
well i looked it up the instructions and
then i actually practiced it on ab2 oh
you already practiced
[Music]
and how did you feel you feel confident
i'm not sure because he wouldn't really
let me like do it i totally saved the
thrusting for the show yeah because you
have to do it really hard yeah yeah
i just practiced the position
all right well let's let's do it let's
see because this could save av's life
right now i'm not
just a reminder i'm wearing olivia's
shirt so if my shirt rises
how why is he wearing your shirt olivia
how'd that happen he loves it
it was on aiea like you have a shirt
yeah yeah
but okay
so here we go
this is uh lena potentially saving
abey's life he's a cr a chronic choker
as we as we noted a tight little
[ __ ] throat yeah what would you
because his esophagus is too narrow
yeah oh
uh would you like me to to read the
official kind of narrate this with the
go ahead i love the guidelines yes
please got some corporate music going
too hi
welcome to the h3 podcast today we'll be
learning how to perform the heimlich
maneuver
first
give five back blows stand to the side
and just behind a choking adult
place one arm across the person's chest
for support
bend the person over at the waist so
that the upper body is parallel with the
ground whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa you
better you better
lena
bend the person over at the waist so
that the upper body is parallel with the
ground deliver five separate back blows
between the person's no no no no no no
no no that's not getting the food out
lina you gotta yeah his life is on the
line
i feel like the waiter right now just
watching it all on foreign anything
okay now
uh if it has not been dislodged after
the back blows give five abdominal
thrusts perform five abdominal thrusts
known as the heimlich maneuver now
pretend he's dying lina this is serious
five thrusts
thrust his ass
let's see it
he's dying he's crying he's joking
oh my god
how did it feel
did it feel did did you feel like that
would force it out of your throat
yes or my ribs would break
that's but it's that serious bro it
looked pretty legit okay
now now you have to choke up we have
brought a steak here for you to
maybe we're gonna do a real simulation
all right that's important now
i don't think you could heimlich me hila
i think i would choke to death
i don't think you could you could do
enough force
[Music]
you i would try you want to try it
where does it work
it's between the belly button and the
rib cage directly in between
also i'm so fat it's hard to get in
there but maybe it's helpful maybe i'll
help we'll see all right let's go elo
you can also do it on yourself if you're
really in panic
yeah against the sure
[Applause]
all right so once again
one step step a little bit further in
so i'm gonna bend over then hit my back
yeah hard
harder you gotta be parallel with the
ground
you gotta bend over more bend over more
ethan
wait wait wait
make a fist and put the thumb towards
his belly and then use the other hand to
to tighten in all right now thrust is
out yeah
i think i'm dying
[Music]
for a long time
[Music]
thank you this has been the h3 podcast
presentation of the heimlich maneuver
i'm afraid i'm going to die this is a
little psa yeah
now if i was actually choking to death
you think the adrenaline would let you
yeah yeah okay good yeah that's not
going to cut don't worry
that's not going to help
wow that was educational i mean listen
with the amount of people watching
there's a good chance that somebody's
life somebody's learned something
through there yeah on this day
somebody may have been joking in real
time and
needed instruction right in the moment i
know i'm watching it back because
there's a slight delay and i'm dude i'm
gonna die bro you're you're not doing it
enough from this the lie you're
literally just humping me no i'm not
you're like thrusting your hips into my
butt well that's just that after
oh bring on a lot of these tutorials we
were watching a lot of the like comments
said like thank god i watched this short
video because it helped me save
someone's life so there it is yeah okay
so if you put your hand in a fist the
same way you as you as you would do
towards someone else and put it like
above your belly button and then you
place the fist between the back of a
chair and jump on it on oh [ __ ] you can
do it on yourself those are desperate
times yeah
[Music]
if you're alone joking yes life or death
you know
um this is huge okay this is good
everyone remember what we learned here
today somebody asked when is the tf sale
and it's going to go for a week it's a
week yeah yeah someone said uh
uh
ba highland said you look stunning today
thank you all right let's thank our
sponsor we only have one so let's just
get through this and then we'll get on
to some fun segments here
hello fresh
damn damn look at that food oh it looks
so good what is it it's hello fresh okay
let's go
this is sweet chili pork and cabbage
stir-fry with cilantro and crispy fried
onion
sorry
what
these are all pictures taken from super
troopers that submitted it thank you
guys to everyone who submitted it
looks amazing what is hello fresh hello
fresh send you farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep skip
the trips to the grocery store and count
on hellofresh to make home cooking easy
fun and affordable and that's why it's
america's number one meal kit
yes sir skip the grocery store and spend
more time soaking up the summer sun
hella fresh market is a one-stop shop
oh what's that tell me more about that
one
oh you know what we reached out to them
and we wanted to we said can we get a
baby's recipe i want that
i said let's make this thing or at least
give us the code abe burrito or
something
burrito's in the chat folks
dang that schnitzel
no all this stuff looks so good anyway
what i was saying was uh you know soak
up the summer raise because hellofresh
is a one-stop shop for all your meal
time needs and a quick breakfast lunch
snack dessert or more
it's a foolproof step-by-step recipes
uh for joyful cooking experience in a
stress-free summer plus
plus hellofresh cuts back on time spent
in the kitchen with meals ready in 30
minutes or less
listen they send you all the damn that
looks fire
they send you all the ingredients
they tell you exactly what to do with it
you don't waste food
you get the perfect amount it's healthy
it's wholesome it's balanced
it's so freaking good
if you're an amateur or or an
experienced chef you're still gonna you
can learn a lot
and i think that's really good for
people who are scared of cooking this is
a great way to get in there
i love hellofresh this food looks
incredible
also guys the best parts here go to
hellofresh.com after dark 16 and use the
code after dark 16 for up to 16 free
meals and three free gifts
that's hellofresh.com
after dark 16.
use the code after dark 16 for up to 16
free meals america's number one meal kit
ella fresh thank you
okay yeah
get after it
[Music]
all right let's get on so now the first
thing i want to do here guys yes let's
start with the howie mandel
competition yeah competition because
this this is the one that i'm most
excited about what do we do about it do
you think howie saw my tick tock with 12
million views
maybe
i think so i wonder if he understood it
or was it just confused well i was
posting some to my insta stories a bunch
of them and he texted me he said nice
stories does it
i couldn't tell if it was sarcastic or
if you liked it for real
you know
but um regardless
so let's see
um
we have uh
what is this
so that's why i say tweet wait what's
the fat donut connection with the howie
meme
so we mentioned previously on the show
well i don't know does someone else want
to introduce this actually it's not my
baby
sam i just don't understand the prolapse
to the donut or well i guess i do yeah
yeah you made some joke about it right
okay i remember so austin told us you
know if you don't like ace fest to suck
a fat donut
here he is so that's why i say tweeters
okay so real quick for the people that
said that our festival was a scam or
that it wasn't happening you guys can
suck a fat
donut okay because it's happening so yes
so i took that to heart because we
definitely ate crow in this case and
specifically donut what do you think he
meant when he said suck a fat donut
because to me it sounds like a bottle
i think that does sound like it like the
like the family friendly version of
saying that so fat donut reminds me of
the image we couldn't show which was
howie's prolapse
so what we did
is that sam being crafty
culinary
genius created a donut that looks like
howie's prolapse
and so this is the closest we're going
to get to being able to show you guys
what it looked like and also i'm going
to suck a fat doughnut which also has a
collapse okay right that's him i call it
the dough laps
we'll bring it out don't believe me
hanging
oh jesus
give me a bite of that dolaps well
ela should see
the real one before before the dawn okay
right right so ela hasn't seen the um
prolapse yet
and we got her to agree this i wonder
how many people haven't seen it on um we
posted on on our twitter so everyone who
wanted to see it
and if you if you never saw it and you
want to see it you can go ahead and
scroll back on our tweet now this is
ela's first time now this was posted on
howie mandel
family friendly howie mandel for three
million people go ahead yolo look at it
when my friend hilo
does somebody know is this covid related
and if it is what do we do about it what
do you see describing oh i don't know
what am i seeing
can you just there's like a hole in the
underwear what am i seeing yeah yeah
yeah ripped open i think we determined
that it's some kind of fetish thing no
yeah not a photo
yeah but like it's pretty wild because
like the ring is all purple and there's
like butt hairs but it's so wide
yeah i can't and then this is what i
said looks like a halfway inside out
sock yuck
yeah i don't know it scares me i feel
like the more i look at it this is gonna
happen to me for some reason i don't
know why this doesn't happen actually
it's contagious yeah it's not gonna
happen
but um can you believe he posted that no
when my friend neal bent over this
happened
does somebody know is this covid related
and if it is what do we do about it
[Applause]
so there you have it do you want to
describe it no no okay well bring out
the donut sam and then at least you
could say
how much the donut looks like
oh my god wow
yeah thank you thank you
whoa
pretty identical check it out damn this
is heavy eh wow it's got some it's got
some weight some heft it really does
look like it oh god
so this is the closest we're gonna be
able to get to showing you guys
but yeah
it is this wide that's what's
interesting about it and let me just
give you guys an idea
[Laughter]
what do we do about it
oh my god
oh
lord that is what it looks like
yeah it's really interesting but anyway
this one goes out to austin mcbroom
i'm gonna suck a fat donut for you and
uh well here we go that donut okay
what are they doing
[Music]
it's just a doughnut down yeah
that's really good someone sent this to
austin
mmm
coming in with that heat
[Music]
what's inside of the prolapse
it's cake pop though oh my god
oh everyone got a prolapse
there's yeah there's a there's a few
more but
thank you there's some regular ones too
in case anybody was grossed out i think
the business discipline should pick this
up then you can start selling that
it's heavy right yeah
um
so we're actually all sucking a fat
doughnut that's got some girth to it
careful lifting that you might you know
oh wow that's a great tasting ass man
mm-hmm
i wish i could taste the
oh don't do it
remember joe pesci said
yeah
[ __ ] sam this is amazing wait you guys
gotta eat it from the producer yeah
yeah you can't eat it from the side it's
like the greatest
donut i've ever had oh so like wait
that's like just wrong like this you
didn't yeah yeah yeah yeah
or is it like this
that works
that's what he's into which is exactly
what detected dude i qualify for a
veterans discount because i had to look
at the reference photo like a hundred
times i was making these right
you for your service
you really nailed it
thank you
and um
please someone make sure austin sees
this
donut okay
[Music]
all right sam what this is amazing holy
[ __ ] yeah i'm so glad that's good
yum
and what's on the bottom just a donut
donut yeah
so i it's a donut and then i made cake
pop dough and i put it in the hole and
then i made like the
the ring
what the crust i don't know like
the ring part and then the actual like
prolapse part out of the dough and then
i covered it in fondant and then i made
like different color icing and i painted
it on you're a genius dude
can i say you seemed excited to add the
hairs and i noticed there's no hairs on
this what happened there so i bought
something that i've never used before it
was called like iso malt and it's what
you make hard candy out of i believe so
i don't think i melted it down
long enough because you're supposed to
be able to like uh pull it and it comes
off in like little strands oh and um
so it just didn't it didn't work out
that's a shame that sounds like it would
have been awesome yeah i gotta tell you
that ass has a lot of calories in it man
but it's good
it's [ __ ] good i wonder if [ __ ] has a
lot of calories
interesting
[Music]
you don't think so olivia no i just
don't want to talk about it
well it's an interesting question i
don't think anyone i think it's
something that's worth discussing
like calories
nutritional
calories come from
you know your body absorbing nutrients
in the food and i don't think i mean
[ __ ] has already had all the nutrients
taken out so i would imagine it's local
i'm gonna eat your ass does [ __ ] have a
lot of calories the bottom line
while you might feel lighter after
pooping you're not actually losing much
weight
that's not what i had
i don't think enough people have asked
how many colors when you're a few shoes
i think i found it
stool calories per gram were five
uh kilograms or i don't know what the
[ __ ] that means stool calories loss at a
percentage of digesting
was 7.3
so you only lose 7.3 of the original
calories
percent
what did you find
olivia same thing
right
does having diarrhea burn calories
someone asked somebody just said [ __ ] is
keto
is that true i don't know it depends how
much bread you ate probably that's right
right [ __ ] you know what has anyone ever
googled that is [ __ ] keto
a new google unlocked
that ass tastes so good
can i eat poop and is it keto
[Music]
it's not it's not getting me there it
says is keto does keto give you the
poops
hmm come on google step your shirt
[Music]
all right well let's get started on the
howie memes
um
we made a super compilation do we have
the names of everyone who submitted
these
i mean we can
reverse engineer it easily but not it's
not listed well i need to know who made
the james charles one because i posted
that and it did get 12 million views so
they they deserve some acknowledgement
that was a3 progressive toms
oh go
the one that yeah like the parody
account that has our name but felt wrong
yeah to make
we both choking i got you
i'm like a be quick get in there a.b
no i'm not i can breathe i'm fine i'm
talking do it anyways ap no
[Laughter]
you just want to hug him
ethan
remember that curb episode where they
bring the like penis cake to um
funkhouser's house or something it was
like the black log cake
and that sounds familiar i'm saying it
they there's the greatest cake they ever
had but they didn't know it was a dick
this is like probably the greatest donut
i've ever had it's an [ __ ] why do i
not remember that oh no right it was
like a penis cake
well here is the best of and thank you
to everybody who submitted these
make up feel free to distribute these
far and wide
and here it is without further ado
when my friend neil bent over this
happened does somebody know is this
covid related and if it is
what do we do about it
ow
when my friend neil bent over this
happened does somebody know is this
covid related and if it is
what do we do about it
oh
when my friend neil bent over this
happened
does somebody know it's a great related
and if it is what do we do about that's
why i need this to happen it's i love it
mean for me but tick tock is determined
to [ __ ] me over bro
we gotta vote the best one and i'll post
the winner or like three of the best
into a compilation okay yeah
i'll do it live right now brad wow
sick
ow
when my friend neil bent over this
happened
does somebody know is this
because they know i love this video
what do we do about it
ow
when my friend i'm not the third
firefighter does somebody know is this
covid related and if it is what do we do
about it
ow
when my friend neil bent over this
happened i don't does somebody know is
this covid related and if it is like
sonic what do we do about it pregnant
sonic ow
when my friend bent over this happened
somebody know is this covid related and
if it is what do we do about it
ow
my friend neil bent over this happened
oh no somebody know is this covid
related and if it is what do we do about
it
please how is elizonka
are you there silly
does somebody know is this covid related
and if it is what do we do about it i
haven't heard a sound bite in a while
hello
wow hey was that when you were blitzed
yes yeah that was yeah
when my friend spongebob man over this
happened
somebody knows this covered related and
if it is
what do we do about it okay oh what the
[ __ ] i do that
on spot on i'll explain i'll explain
after after we watch the rest let's
explain it now
i don't
there's a reason i don't want to explain
it yet okay you'll have to trust me
when my friend neil went over this
happened
does somebody know is this covid related
and if it is what do we do about it
ow
does somebody know is this covid related
[Music]
i don't know if we can even show that
what we're showing this somebody had
oh when my friend neil bent over this
happened i was gonna put him
does somebody know is this covid related
and if it is what do we do about it
ow
when my friend neil bent over this
happened
does somebody know is this covid related
and if it is what do we do about it
ow
when my friend neil went over this
happened
does somebody know this is very good and
if it is
ow
my friend neil bento
does somebody know is this covid related
and if it is what are we going to do
about it
[Music]
spongebob
i got put in there twice
[Music]
[Laughter]
what do we do about it
when my friend neil bent over this
happened
does somebody know him
and if it is what do we do about it
when my friend neil bent over this
happened does somebody know this isn't
good
[Music]
when my friend neil bent over this
happened
does somebody know this is copied
related and if it is
what do we do about it bossman biden
oh no no
this happened
does somebody know is this covid related
and if it is
what do we do about it
what do we do about that's the first
time i've seen what it actually looks
like to the audience by the way straight
up i put olivia's nipple cream on it and
the pain went away really yeah she gave
me nipple cream apparently you put
nipple cream on anything and it fits
together yeah i use it as a chopstick
really
there you go
learning something new every day
ow
when my friend neal bent over this
happened this i don't know does somebody
know is this covid related
when my friend neil bent over this
happened
does somebody know is this covid related
and if it is what do we do about it
oh what was that video by the way love
i was just gonna board so i made like a
stream where i got like a giant burger
with as many patties as possible from
mcdonald's oh they they did that for you
oh yeah i was like arguing with the
manager and [ __ ]
well so tell me about it how much did it
cost uh thirty five dollars
sweet in sweden crowns but uh around 35
bucks yeah
and what was the conversation with the
manager like
well at first i had this one dude who
was super down right like a normal
employee and he he's like yeah sure i
think we can make that happen and then i
like hear something like just russell
like
and like she comes and
how many how many patties do you want
and she said no
and like i tried to argue with her and i
ended up getting like 13 patties in like
a cardboard box and then i had to
reassemble it myself oh okay
she didn't want to assemble it for you
right no and i said like just throw it
in the bag i don't really yeah yeah you
guys presented but
my goal is to have them reset like make
it because that's kind of the funny part
and um how much of this were you able to
eat
uh i ate like probably half wow good for
you pretty good hell yeah brother i
brought it home after and i ate half and
then i had to throw it away because it
got kind of
weird and and how did you feel after
that
oh just fine just nice good for you
buddy thank you it's exciting i got an
idea for dinner now
all right so why wouldn't you tell me
about the spongebob dan
well
i didn't want to influence the vote at
all
but i guess i might as well just tell
you cam made that one
that was your voice cam
no you
used an ai uh oh
yeah
i in fact i feel like that shouldn't be
included
you know well my favorite was the family
it's okay people can vote for it i just
want a banger tick tock
oh okay yeah that's the case but in my
opinion so what were the top ones we
could put it to a poll my favorite was
wendy
that one worked really well very organic
i like cams
thank you is this covid related by the
way
uh 50 gifted subs oh i think i know who
that is it's a shouty benefactor yeah we
love you buddy
so you like the windy one did you like
the cam one any other nominees
jimmy lee i mean i love that one i like
the joe rogan the joe rogan one i'm just
thinking like what's gonna do well on
tick tock the joe rogan one
is hot
hot hot hot hot pot
and we've learned through your james
charles one that nips catch the ice
crush
the nips crush the kermit one big nip
specifically yeah
that one was already posted that's a
tick tock i found
oh but are we feeling then are we
feeling so let's do wendy williams
joe rogan or uh patrick now my thing
with patrick is that i'm not sure people
are gonna get the meme because it's
gotta include howie that's my take
okay
oh love you made the joe rogan one god
bless you
i kind of [ __ ] up i didn't know you
were gonna post it on think dog
so i might have already posted it on
tick tock on my account how did it do
you got like five thousand views it's
pretty so so we'll take i'll take it
from here
yeah
thank you
so let's do a vote i think wendy
joe
[Music]
the thing is the cam one's not gonna
the camera's not gonna do i i know what
you're saying yeah cause people aren't
gonna get the meme reference okay
it's just a little too
out there i'll post it on my own yeah
yes yes and i'll love it and i'll
comment
and i'll say what are we gonna do about
this that clout phil thank you
what do we do about it
so it's just joe rogan and wendy is that
all we got and you say you wanted three
winners so we are what's the what's the
poll just pick one and i'll post it okay
got it yeah wendy joe any other nominees
let's see the kermit i mean i see a lot
of people saying kermit but he said that
that was awesome
that's somebody else's ass that's
already been posted kissing the dad one
oh garyvee
yeah that's pretty funny
one was pretty good too right um but i
don't know if that would be good on tick
tock which one probably removed
crack the one because that one would
yeah that one's pretty good let's no
that won't give me let's we can show it
to our audience now but on tick tock it
would definitely get removed okay yeah
can you pull up the nicocado one oh
that's not what we were talking about
we're talking about the one with your
butt yours
from that oh you think that one would do
good oh for sure but it's going to get
removed yeah get removed just my ass on
tick tock oh yeah
yeah
that's doing so good dude
but for hate for hate
i think anything you post that is james
tick tock has like a thing with you and
jane yeah yeah
i think if it were someone else it may
not i don't think they would care if it
was joe rogan yeah no
and i don't think they'd care if it was
wendy
but yeah they they're protecting james
um i'm just kind of watching the chat to
see like what's popping up the most i'm
seeing a lot of gary v suggestion
i'm talking a decent amount of the halo
one suggested oh wait we have a new
submission neil bent over this happened
does somebody know is this covid related
and if it is
what do we do about it
oh that's pretty funny there it is
that's basically a recreation of the
original
okay so we got joe rogan wendy garyvee
and my bare ass which i don't think we
can post my bear ass yeah also i think
gary vee may get pulled
that one's a bit much i think that one's
gonna get pulled but you know um
i do want to show you the nicacada one i
posted it last night and i got scared
and pulled it down
cause i thought i was gonna get busted
do you want me to pull it up yeah pull
it up it's fine okay i don't think it's
that bad people are posting new ones
um
yeah so check this out
this is one of my favs
and
i
got scared because
i thought
i was probably if i left that
nick one up i'd probably be permanently
banned right now
because it's like the double whammy okay
when my friend neil bent over this
happened
does somebody know is this covid related
and if it is what do we do about it
oh
so i mean i think that's a total banger
yeah it's just a couch it's just a couch
what's so inappropriate about that you
know that'd be my winner dude
so include that one i'll i'll repost it
if y'all think it's a banger you know
what i should just post all of them on
the podcast account yeah
and scatter shopping
on the podcast so maybe
that's kind of a fun idea everything
by the way here's a new howie tic toc
that just dropped that's kind of weird
um this let's see what we have here i'm
growing my hair back people
[Music]
uh
what the [ __ ] what is this
was that meant to look like a ball i'm
gonna say he went from anus to ballsack
howie you're out of control dude dude
he's so funny
i'm growing my hair back people
just stares in silence why does that
look so much like a nut dude
what is it is that real or is it
is it just like a plant or something but
it looks so weird
what do we do about it what do we do
about this howie
does he not realize it looks like a nut
oh i think he does he realizes
i'm growing my hair back people the top
comment is we will always remember
we won't forget howie
how does he keep getting away with this
he's going to get cancer again
no this is this one's not that bad
compared to the prolapse come on now ow
i think how is too innocent i don't
think he realized that looked like a nut
no he does
kidding because he won't come talk to me
about the prolapse like why is he hiding
from it because he knows that it crossed
the line a little bit but he's still
pushing it then with the nut
yeah
but this is like a safe
way
hmm
it's a nice little tufts of hair on that
nut though
definitely ow
okay so i guess we'll just post wait you
say don't post
i just send something don't show it on
screen ian but if you follow the what
howie
duet is just take you to this friendly
hashtag
this is whatever the hell that was bro
what the [ __ ] is that dude
yo what the [ __ ] is that
bro
what is that just like an ai thing
i mean they probably made a something
moving and just put it in like a rubber
can i show this i can show this no what
the heck i'm not sure what it is is that
thing alive what's happening i think
it's just a little robotic thing i'm
gonna show it yeah so this is what howie
posted some weird [ __ ] like this yeah
that's the same hashtag
what's the hashtag what is this
lab banana oh god howie what doubt what
weird [ __ ] are you getting into buddy
oh [ __ ] well [ __ ] balls eh
yeah holy [ __ ] balls that is so [ __ ]
crazy okay so it's
supposedly a banana made in a lab with
human cells in it no no no no no no no
that's for sure not yeah
but people are actually like debating
and [ __ ] just kids probably that's
illegal you literally can't do that
bro what the [ __ ] though it looks hella
good
i just want to know good
good and what way i just i know it looks
creepy it looks creepy not like i want
to [ __ ] suck it off
but he's on howie's explore page that
he's finding all these
i would eat the [ __ ] out of that
but this one didn't get removed i mean
it's been up for a minute
so you know
oh [ __ ] howie you [ __ ] up brother
what are we gonna do about it
all right so what we're we're not gonna
let me post one and then you can post
the rest love let's do a poll god damn
it oh i'm was just waiting for you to
finally got wendy williams joe rogan
nicotto just those three yeah yeah yeah
that's the nominees yeah and then the
winner i'll post right now to tick tock
and pray that i don't get [ __ ]
permanently banned
because you know about it i'm on thin
ice boy
let's see if i can even post i'm not
even sure
now in my opinion um
[Music]
i'm gonna do the joe joe rogan that's
what i voted for
oh right nick is going through [ __ ]
right now
so maybe now is not a good time
people thought he died and [ __ ] because
he like didn't post
but fifty percent said nick ocado
everybody loves the nicocado one
it's too risky
he disappeared for like two weeks and
everyone thought he like died of a heart
attack
and he just announced his divorce
is that was that real
his partner confirmed the split and also
confirmed that he's not dead oh [ __ ]
i heard someone say that he's quitting
uh mukbangs is that true olivia um
i didn't see that maybe i'm not super up
to date i believe i saw it uh someone
was sharing it from his
patreon or only fans saying that he's
losing weight he's done a weight loss
journey that's good that's exciting for
him
thank you uh fat strong so should i end
this poll and do a new one without nick
in there
well listen the people have spoken so
who am i to question uh democratic
process
people are saying wendy williams though
even over joe so maybe it's
maybe it's a a wendy williams thing
man i i hope i wish nick ocado well
though i hope he gets his everything
back on track
love to get him in here
me too you know
dan you ready to go through all that
again try to get nick here
definitely
what do we do about it what do we do
about it
ow
so
i guess let's just post wendy williams
then i don't know
but she's also going through a hard time
when he's going you know what i'm
avoiding i'm not posting [ __ ]
[ __ ] this
yeah just post them all to the the
podcast love yeah that shit's gonna get
banned dude they're all gonna get taken
down we're we're good standing we
haven't got anything removed in a while
okay
there you go guys keep the beep alive
but how we know we will never
forget
and we will never forgive either
what do you guys say is it time for man
vs machine
yeah
the long awaited tournament of
champions cameron
now cameron as we know is one of the
most talented photoshop and quickest
photoshop talents this world has ever
seen yep it's often providing us
incredible memes on the fly
but
he is facing his greatest competitor yet
the dolly 2 machine
this is already logged in i think right
yeah
now let me show you what this thing can
do you guys have probably heard of dolly
one
you type in anything you want and it
generates an image and it's pretty fast
okay
now
um give me you think of anything ela you
can be like uh
anything in this style or anything just
tell me anything you want
any random weird [ __ ]
can i reference like an existing artist
yes in their style yes
so like
a butterfly in a takashi murakami style
a butterfly and you're gonna have to
spell that though
takashi
or uh
did i spell it right i can't okay
m-u-r
oh all right you ready check this out
it's gonna blow your mind you still
spell down what
mu is from
[Music]
you think it'll figure it out
i guess we'll find out
yeah so this is gonna [ __ ] in your tits
bro
wait let me let me try spelling his name
right and see if it
i'm afraid i can't do that
a butterfly and takashi murakami style
all right let's try that again
you ready to get your tits shut on
so the idea is that we're gonna think of
some crazy prompt
cam is gonna process it as well as dolly
too and we'll see who gets closer is
this doesn't i mean this one is kind of
like his style in it
it did not [ __ ] on my tits it didn't
[ __ ] on your tits
okay
all right well not impressive this
wasn't the best showing a good example
would be like gandalf in the matrix is
one of the ones okay
gandalf and the matrix this one's pretty
impressive
[Music]
okay
dolly 2 is processing our request
the gears are churning
prepare your tits to be [ __ ] on look at
this
that's crazy isn't it yeah that's cool
look at this [ __ ]
yeah that's really cool i love when it
does text gordon look at this [ __ ]
gorton diff this
i've heard you can get some pretty
creepy stuff if you do like the one who
asked
just that the one you asked
all right let's see that's pretty
abstract request
okay dolly two is um processing our
request the one who asked
your tits been [ __ ] on yet
[Music]
okay that was super underrated very
creepy yeah wait i heard one i saw one
that they said was creepy was just
mirror
mere selfie
and yielded some really creepy results
real quick i want to give a thank you to
iodice for giving us access to this oh
yeah thank you king
you're selfies
oh no those are totally normal
well okay let me just try to blow your
tits off here um a mix watch this okay
just just totally random a mcdonald's
[ __ ] i can't see
mcdonald's on the moon
in the style of van
gogh
did he spell his name
get down
like that it's a space it's two two
words
like that
a mcdonald's on the moon in the style of
van gogh okay
that's pretty nuts right all right let's
see
[Music]
this is an ai generated
in about 30 seconds
check this out
that's crazy
that's like a cool original art yeah
that's really cool you know
look at this
that's nuts
and then like
that's actually cool art this one missed
the mark what the hell is this one
i don't know
but that's pretty amazing isn't it yeah
and then if i remove van gogh you can
see it just ends up with a
really you just completely make this one
up or you saw somebody no no i just
thought of it that's really cool
completely made up
so i'm just going to type mcdonald's on
the moon now stop playing that
it's driving the chat notes and it's
driving me nuts too it's very loud it's
very loud so here i type mcdonald's on
the moon that's really cool you know
what i mean yeah or you could do
mcdonald's on the moon
photo
realistic
oh
okay
it doesn't let you do anything vulgar
okay or like graphic we try it's kind of
fun to try to get around it yeah that
was like a whole challenge the other day
but
here's a photorealistic
mcdonald's on the moon yeah incredible
so that also doesn't let you uh look at
this
any public figures or anything like that
okay i was gonna ask about that yeah
yeah so the thing is it pulls from
a database of photos so even if you try
to be like lady with big old titties or
whatever it wouldn't let you but it
doesn't have titties in the database so
it can't really conceptualize what that
is in any in any way
so um let's see
basically
let's begin this this journey
okay wish me luck guys
so we need to think of something totally
off the walls
okay
and also i'm gonna need a little more
time than like sure sure no you got 30
seconds
just getting screwed
okay how about
this a wizard
or a cam's wheelhouse here a wizard give
him a softball wearing a bathrobe
eating a hamburger
okay you really got hamburgers on your
mind
for dinner tonight
a wizard wearing a bathroom eating a
hamburger
all right cam get to work
i wish we did we have a shot of cam's
like fingers on the keyboard like a
hacking scene that would be cool
[Laughter]
all right get hacking buddy
cam is a meme machine for those who
don't know cam was sending uh memes even
before he worked for the show
yep
instantly
oh [ __ ] look at his fingers go oh my god
he's working so fast now let's see what
the machine generated
this is a wizard huh in a bathrobe
eating a hamburger
interesting this one this is kind of
dope
he's got even got a wrapper in his hand
so how does this work it's just like a
free-to-use thing or what is the purpose
of it so the first one was free to use
yeah
this second one's still in beta
and i think what it's going to
eventually be used for is you pay for a
license and the thing is you're never
gonna have to buy royalty-free [ __ ]
and instead of having to photoshop
anything or create assets you literally
just type it in this [ __ ] it's
incredible and then the other cool thing
is like
this one's kind of epic and then
you can generate more like pick your
favorite one okay which one's your
favorite
top right
okay so now we can go
uh
variations and it will generate more
they'll look like it's so cool fine tune
it down
there's a wizard
and a bathrobe eating a hamburger so
in this kind of
way of thinking can you also like do
clothing designs in it yeah i tried that
you tried it but i not a lot but i think
we should try that more
so here is um a wizard in a bathrobe
he's also this guy's got a banana
this one's got french fries
see they made that association
because they're looking more [ __ ] up
like a image
yeah there you have it
[Music]
so i think this is our fave right
all right cam the clock's running out
almost all right
now obviously we're giving cameron a
little extra time because he
has a mere human being
a fupa trooper said what sucks is that
the creators use a ton of art without
permission but are hoping to put those
artists out of work
they're saying that they using in their
database a shitload of images
that they don't have to license
and then
creating a service that's going to take
right that's true i don't know what to
say about that but
this is the future i mean it is
interesting
what is the permission like on this kind
of uh that's a new legal issue that yeah
probably hasn't been explored you know
yeah
all right cameron
i'm gonna have to call it
i'm gonna have to call it cam
[ __ ] all right hold on uh i'll just drop
what i got but it's not good i know i
already lost this round
well let's see
don't be too sure
a wizard in a bathrobe
eating a hamburger
i forgot can you be specific with names
in this version
like can you name a specific person
like uh i don't think if they're a
public character
okay all right we got it i gotta say i i
gotta cover my ass here this is just my
warm-up round well hold on
it's not good here's cameron's it's not
good
what do we think it's just a warm-up
it's not bad
should we vote or just move on let's do
another vote
let's this is the warm-up round this is
the one yeah all right but that's not
bad cam that's not bad it's not good i
vote for cam
thanks love all right let's get weirder
let's get um
another person said concept artists just
need to learn to use it which
could it could definitely be a great
tool to like
show concepts really quick well that's
what cameron said he says he wants to
work with the machine right yeah they
spit it out and you perfect it right you
know i think unfortunately
or not i don't know
i haven't thought that much about it but
it's probably fair use to use the
images in this way
although it's not been legally
challenged so who knows
right
okay
new prompts let's think of something
really weird
there's somebody currently in labor but
could not miss the show what
call in
call in vanessa yeah call in
we're here for you vanessa
okay how about this a monster made out
wait
a monster
made out of human fingers
let's see what we get
oh dude i was doing some really effed up
once yesterday i was like the pope
with a shirtless child
and it was getting weird bro it was
it was good
okay what do we have here okay so i
gotta say cam
this is not a good one
i think i said a monster made out of
human fingers okay
nah it's not i don't see a single
monster here
that's [ __ ] weird though yeah
that's weird as hell
i guess that one's kind of
yeah that one's pretty good actually
should we perfect like a variation let's
do that one i feel like you might come
up with some uh some decent ones stick
your finger by the way if you guys have
any suggestions send them a discord or
if you guys see any good ones in the
chat let me know
okay yeah i like that
wow okay interesting
um
yeah so
okay interesting cam
you're up
yeah the original was the best of that
set
oh somebody here while cam works on that
let's mess around in
some other prompts
um
let's duplicate
somebody said george abe uh george
washington wearing teddy fresh
i wonder if it knows what teddy fresh is
right we're about we did teddy fresh at
one point and it did spit out like sort
of like a color blocky looking really
thing yeah
that's crazy
what happens if you do like questions
prompts like how does the world end and
stuff
what the [ __ ] this is
no
that is not it
okay let's try something george
washington wearing supreme
george washington
somebody said tim poole no beanie that's
funny but most
uh
you know
people that are
famous
that they're alive still uh it blocks it
won't do it
absolutely all of it yeah
it's giving you tips are waiting for the
stanza doing the doogie
oh yeah this this is not oh this one's
kind of fire
i gotta say i could easily get this
though but i'm almost done with the
fingers so hold on
all right let me try someone abstract
like love was choosing how the world
ends
how does the world end
well i don't think i don't think you
want to pose a question more like
how the world ends ow
you want me to say how it does
well that was that was what he was
asking is how does it handle questions
but does it need to be like a something
something like a world ending
on the earth yeah i think it should be
like the earth ending
it's more omnious if you ask it how it
ends in my opinion right how does the
world end do i put in a question mark or
no yeah sure let's just see what it see
what it thinks
we're just asking questions they all
start with a
basically the more descriptive the
better i feel like right yes
they're showing you examples a few
series of cyborg posts
style paintings not questions yo these
ones suck bro yeah
wait the bottom left
what is the ominous black spiral on this
guy that one
um
this the bottom left
do ethan klein eating at a dentist
i'll try to do that
a fat
podcaster a fat white jewish man a fat
white jewish with a great hairline
with a with with gray hair with gray
hair and tiny hands with gray hair and
tiny hands
eating at a denny's
let's see putting this thing to the test
oh
it didn't work i think jewish
a fat white man
with gray hair
and tiny hands eating at a denny's
okay
by the way i put my finger guy in
we got a finger guy
so
this is interesting a five man
with gray hair
and tiny hands
eating at a denny's with tiny hands
can you click back to uh
dude this is a real denny's eater bro
see i was never at denny's it was this
guy he didn't look like me
all right if you could go back to the
original uh
hand monster and i have uh so this was
our pick right and you ready for cams
all right let's see kim
that's a clear winner right if i had
more time it could be like more refined
obviously and like the lighting and
everything but this is just yeah you did
it in like two minutes man yeah that's
way better a monster
made of human fingers
bunger
bunkers it's a fungal monster that's a
cameron w right there yep
wow
the machine ain't there yet
okay here's one from ian um
abe lincoln in a hardcore punk band
all right let's just give that a shot
let's see what we get
[Music]
here we go should i play oh should i do
this one
uh
yeah this is the one yeah this is the
challenge is it
oh [ __ ] let's see
oh that's kind of sick that's kind of
cool
lincoln abba
let's go lynn's labs
that's fire really good
that's
fire
this stuff is a really good way to
generate a concept and then you like
pick your favorite and then you actually
go spend right
so which is your guys's favorite this
one or
i think that first one's pretty good
maybe
that bottom middle one is really good
yeah so maybe let's
do some variations on this
i like that without telling it directly
it it did it in the style of like yeah
that's cool punk uh
show flyer wait
is that love what did you just send
because that one has my it looks like me
is that the old version
all right so let's see abe lincoln and a
punk band
that one why that didn't really look
like abe anymore does it unfortunately i
think the top one is still the best
all right let's show you you had an
interesting idea to generate
design ideas
so all right what would you type in here
like
um can you do like um color block hoodie
90s
style
just curious i don't know
okay
let's see
let's go
oh i should type in hawaiian shirt and
see what comes up that'll be the real
[Laughter]
true so many shots said that they use it
for game design that's crazy
that's interesting so there you go i
mean not they're not really that great
but no but incentives
yeah
um
how about this
a mario
mario
wearing
mario wearing
a hawaiian
shirt
he's so cool
and luigi
and bondage
[Music]
he's so cool
let's see what these two goons look like
oh bondage
and luigi shirtless
with
no shirt
all right cameron has submitted his um
his response okay he's done already yeah
he's done that was fast i didn't want to
interrupt sorry
so let's pull that up after this yeah
okay
okay
dude
but do you see what i'm saying guys this
is the hawaiian vibes
the machine knows it you know it we all
know it i don't know a lot of those
don't really have like floral patterns
on them yeah what the [ __ ] is this
floral what's this is floral it's a very
like abstract way of
floral i don't know floral
floral come on
we all know it polka dot
on luigi all right so can't so pull up
cams let's see whoa
that's [ __ ] sick dude
i mean obviously cams is better
there's a triumph they're different
it is not way better dolly mini sucks
it's only better for using like
celebrities that are still alive yeah
that one isn't as restrictive but it's
like nightmare fuel when you
what it spits out right
well cam that's another job for cam
oh thank you
i honestly think the computer took that
round
all right let's really challenge cameron
here with one of these ones that it
would be really good at like that
let's see
somebody said a comedian on the street
uh with security guards asking for audio
a comedian on the street
comedian on the street
with
[Music]
security guards
and
video crew
crew but his audio doesn't work
well that's a lot
an old man slicing a beach ball at a
dodgers game oh that's a good one
we gotta that's great we gotta do that
one next i'm just reading suggestions
here keep the suggestions coming guys
wow yo that
is pretty weird and creepy
wow these are wild dude
they're so wild
okay okay okay
[Laughter]
oh how about this so a man chokes on
steak at sizzler
oh
yeah chokes on steak be more specific
say a young a young
man with blonde highlights
you know i mean let's let's see if we
can get it to spit out an a b
big eyes a young man with blonde
highlights big big old
eyes
okay so i have
a young man with blonde highlights and
big eyes chokes on steak at sizzler
and then we'll do the dad's one next i
want to see what that is
so what says a woman crying on her
kitchen floor are we allowed to do that
ela no
[Music]
these are pretty wild man
these are i don't know about choking not
it
no these are bad oh my god no okay so an
old man
an old man stat stabbing probably won't
work eh right an old man slicing slicing
a beach ball
with a pocket knife at a dodger game
there it is and in the role of a
lifetime
gary gary allman playing a little person
yeah remember
gary gary
here it is
to take a look
does it look familiar
not at all
[Music]
you said the way that you look at the
face i mean what yeah what's in god's
name
okay that one's this one's that one's
pretty good
that means apple onion
that's a woman
cutting a cantaloupe or something [ __ ]
yo the machine is kind of letting us
down today a little bit countless tree
man with a bowl cut at an empty stadium
definitely not
not [ __ ] on anyone's tits no no tits
are being [ __ ] on i'm afraid i can't do
that maybe you could try more mystical
things like unicorn on the moon and
stuff like that i know that's
up yeah um a few people are saying we
need update on vanessa
who's in labor oh yeah did vanessa
contact anyone we need to get the
can we get a video in there vanessa
unicorn on the moon
shooting lasers from his horn
that should be a slam dunk slam dunk no
yeah do you want cam to do this one wait
what unicorn on the moon shooting lasers
from its horn that didn't i guess shoot
word
all right you want to do this one kim
you could just say with lasers coming
out of its horn
wait sorry say it again i was i'm almost
done with the uh this is how slowly i'm
almost done with the comedian one but
okay
what was this what was the problem go
ahead with that one
yeah don't
don't let us distract you
all right we've got unicorn on the moon
with lasers coming from his horn now i'm
trying to [ __ ] on mila's tits here
oh now that's fire okay
that's insane
i just put the medium one in there not
insane but it's pretty good not insane
that's right on the money right there
that's literally what i asked for
all right here is uh cam's
interpretation of the comedian with
security on the street
uh
jamie can i check the audio
that's pretty good that's awesome that's
a dub yeah
thanksgiving dinner
but
instead of turkey
that's probably not a good way to phrase
it thanksgiving dinner
with
um
oh thanksgiving dinner
but the
but the turkeys are
eating humans
okay somebody suggested try a random
date in the future could we do something
like that okay
let's try that
thanksgiving dinner but the turkeys are
eating humans nasty didn't get that
the meaning of life i've got to try this
again turkeys eating
thanks
to eating humans
at thanks
giving dinner let's try that
turkey's eating
human fingernails
turkeys eating humans at thanksgiving
dinner dropped a uh
grumpy fat man on mobility scooter with
small hands driving into drywall
see this one totally
totally missed the moment
oh [ __ ] that's gnarly
i'm almost done
no
dude
what
oh oh my god
yo
what the going for it girl what's
happening
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's crazy i was
all sweaty too
that's kind of sick
yeah it's interesting
try
um
batman on
a mobility scooter
and fat
all right see i don't think i'm phrasing
it right it'd be like
hold on
it should be like fat batman on mobility
yeah
right i can't even do it you know
i mean batman on a mobile he's writing
on the back
see that that's that's in craig that's
batman on a mobility scooter dude yeah
that's pretty well joker church
fat batman on a mobility the joker
church
so here's the camera
joker
at thanksgiving dinner eating humans
that's pretty wild it's closer than it
got yeah
that's great yeah that's really cool
actually there it is cameron wins again
guy has no chance
all right here's look at this dude
that's that is insane
i love you profile photo alert yeah
holy [ __ ] to disability mobility
[Laughter]
[Music]
dude these are all good
yeah look at this sheila
wow
so there you go you know that one hit
pretty hard yeah
um
how about joker
joker
joker brain up a building in the style
of pixar
okay
maybe blowing up a building won't work
let's see
yeah
joker
destroying ability
let's try that
all right
joker destroying a building in the style
of pixar
huh
is this pixar so and it's interesting
this is interesting
that's not really pixar though is it
it's more like
what you [ __ ] deserve sorry it kind
of looks like the opening animations of
incredibles that's the only thing i
could okay interesting
um
all right say say what say what uh uh
ian
he said 3d animated style
joker specific
what if you do joke her brain
choke her brain okay sure let's see what
we got you know we believe in society
we live in the society
i see this prompt says digital art or
you could do like photorealistic digital
art
and vaporwave yeah
joker brain
oh this is interesting
that's [ __ ] sick dude
yeah they're kind of thick
well that's dope jorker yeah
yorker brain wait go back to the
it's the one before
kind of looks like leto a little bit
okay
yo that's this one's dope
okay well there you go you know
joker brain and vaporwave
white man eating pesto sauce i'm looking
at the chat you guys have some good ones
here
pesto
feces
you know
wow these are these are really good
joker brain
vaporwave charker
joke jerker joke jerker joker church
joker church
i wonder if it'll do feces let's say
guys give me let me look in the chat
give me give me a good one
[Music]
um
i've got a wife who went for pizza
without him
let's try pesto feces
what we would be doing without men
no yeah
still want you to do a date in the
future
okay so let's say uh june
25th that's my birthday
and uh
2 100.
just a date that's it they set a date in
the future i'm afraid i can't i'm just
going to give like a calendar or
something
dan you're on you might be
underestimating the mystic power do you
think it's gonna predict the future here
it's a beautiful day
it's a gorgeous day so much to look
forward to
can't wait
that kind of
[Music]
city post-apocalyptic in the background
are we
a little bit full day it's a beautiful
day
yeah it's just sunset what about you
putting lonely men pooping in a walmart
lone okay lonely yeah lonely man i don't
know if pooping's gonna work squatting
ruining his pants
right let's try squad i'm [ __ ]
myself man squatting in a walmart
maybe i'm gonna pee in my trash can down
here i don't know
all right let's see oh this is wow
wow
okay
i feel bad for him i don't see squatting
so much as
sitting i'm already taking my pants off
all right uh let's try a couple a couple
more here
muddy pants
muddy pants
where's the best place
people want muddy pants oh brawless wife
uh a braless wife bringing
bringing a gamer uh with blue hair a
sandwich
[Music]
bringing a gamer with okay sandwich oh
yeah this is really good
oh did i write bradley it's hard oh yeah
i did
that poor woman has no brad
so hold on i gotta i'm gonna have to
redo this
oh so
we're gonna do a
braless
so the thing is
braless isn't really a word a word
a wife with
okay a wife with no bra
i can't even keep up i'm just admiring
the machine yeah i think you won cam i
think yeah i mean yours were clear
winners clear winner a wife with no bra
bringing a gamer with blue hair sample
and add photo oh you already hit enter
it's going to say add photo realistic at
the end let's see the no bro if you want
to do vulgar stuff we might want to try
the dali meanie
a wife
i'll just do a wife bringing in a gamer
with blue hair sandwich because
it's not going to show some titties
knock it over my wife
you guys see any good suggestions in
there
crazy man stop taking his benzos
let's see what we got here that's a man
bringing a wife a sandwich that's all
[Music]
backwards this thing is super confused
okay
that one he's like that yeah that one
actually that one is actually pretty
good
what did you which one did you say eli
um it's a
a crazy man who stopped taking his
benzos a crazy man
who stopped
taking you want me to say benzos or
medicine i did not maybe medicine so i'm
taking his medicine
so this is jordan peterson a fact
clearly
uh but but somebody suggested a garden
gnome with a bandana wearing a shirt
while in a swimming pool teenage girl
that i like a really good suggestion
yeah that i like
here this is jordan peterson i did not
[ __ ] my door i did not [ __ ] my dog
okay a a
a garden gnome a garden gnome with a
bandana with a bandana on his head on
his head
wearing a shirt
a shirt while in a pool in a swimming
pool with a teenage girl
that's a lot that's a lot i honestly
think it does better when it has more to
work with
roll it
like rolling gnome with a banana on his
head wearing a shirt in the pool with a
teenage girl
the thing i think it's good when you
describe one thing but this is a very oh
[ __ ] it nailed it
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] you guys
oh my god
enhance yourself shame on him for this
that one's oh god guys
oh
shame on you dude
[Laughter]
oh my god shame on you man
they're faces
this one's the best right
yeah let's get some variations going
what a dis what a creep
what a freaking creep
[Laughter]
yeah we need to describe more real-life
stuff here
let's see
oh god this one's bad
what it's getting crazier
he's turned into a smurf
you don't like that one olivia
i mean i just wasn't expecting jazz well
i wasn't expecting a creature
one is great i think i think he'll
really appreciate this brad the bull
runs away with millionaire's wife brad
the bull runs away with million
millionaires
brad the bull
[Music]
disgraced movie producer
eat ethan let's see
oh that's a good one that ela suggested
or do you see that from the chat chat
cowboy with a tiny hat
you know it smells pretty fun
oh that could be brad that's kind of
good drive angry
the truth is it's like jacked israeli
dude
right here let's try that one
let's say
muscular
musculature
[Music]
did i spell it wrong with the top oh
[ __ ] i can't see it so far away
muscular israeli man runs away with
millionaire's wife
i've seen people add 4k photo to the end
of theirs too to get like
yeah if you specify like photo or
something photorealistic it tends to
spit out
something a little better
the thing is we can't put oh these are
horrible
what what
so weird
so weird
all right couple more what do we got
anything else we got good
papa john's day of reckoning okay i like
that
papa john's
papa john's
day of reckoning
will come
this should be interesting
[Music]
oh that's a good one elo
stay tuned stay tuned the day of
reckoning will come
all right let's take a look
john
jaisa
little prolambo
this is just a personalized note from
papa i think in whatever language that
is it's a threat
papanis
janina papes jah
[Music]
that's kind of dope yeah i could see
that as like
a poster that a resistance movement is
posting on the side of papa john's
stores all over the country
wow
i gotta say i'm not as impressed as i
thought i would be from this i gotta say
oh disneyland meets coachella
[Laughter]
let's try that see what that looks like
can you send that one that you suggest
oh you did okay
the other one i want to try is man
drinking at eight a.m while admiring
natalie portman pictures i think it's
going to block natalie portman
disneyland meets coachella
three fingers why why do they have three
fingers see this is where i would come
in
the air if you're about it
[Music]
it's funny that they interpret coachella
as just a handsome stupid influencer
that's awesome
that's so funny
um
how about this an empty fair
in the desert
[Music]
fat donut okay
an empty fair in the desert
[Music]
that's a good one eb
chat
here did this did that's exactly what
ace fest looked like in the beginning of
the day yep
what is this
is that porta potties
it looks like horse racing that's
awesome
yo that's good exactly right there
love that
pretty good
all right so here we'll do a couple more
man drinking at 8 a.m while admiring
yeah natalie portman's not going to work
a picture of a young young actress
oh [ __ ]
child actress yeah a child actress
inappropriate relationship why don't we
just say or what was admiring a young
child a young girl what was the
character's name in the movie that he
was talking about
the professional
natalie portman's character name
uh
mathilda
mathilda from the professional i'm doing
man drinking at 8 am while admiring a
picture of a young girl
too much wine sorry
[Music]
yeah this one's for you cap cap
[Music]
thank you
you're welcome buddy thank you anything
for you
wow that that just missed the mark
all right this is the last one
donkey kong storming normandy beaches
during d-day
[Music]
is there any style you want this in
uh photo realistic
okay
photo realistic
realistic
okay
well there you have it not that good
someone said just write sound bites that
like that we use a lot
might be fun something is about about
donkey
okay this is interesting
well it's a photorealistic
[Music]
[Laughter]
is it safe to say you got to keep my job
though the robot's not taking my job
yeah not yet
not yet
so um sandal wearing man eaten by angry
redhead
the hell does that mean
man with a pointy beard riding a roller
coaster with an outrageously large hat
all right any other last ones before i
move on this robot okay here's one last
night sucks
a man
using a drain in the basement because
wife left for pizza dude there's no way
this can be coherent
let's try it though hahahaha i'm
[ __ ] my basement
that's a good one okay we're gonna end
with cameron
shaking hands with the robot
okay there we go the quartering
whoa
whoa
oh my god okay
oh my god oh my god
all right we're calling it truce now
a robot taking camera's job
no
[Music]
what the [ __ ] that original one's crazy
dude
sorry cam but
i got campbell yeah this robot sucks bro
i'm tired of this [ __ ] cameron is doing
a fantastic job i think he's a star the
pope
[ __ ] in
a small
shirtless
child
nah
you don't think so yeah but that's real
embarrassing
we're gonna say no people say no to that
one
okay how about this o.j simpson oh see
because that's the real person yeah that
won't work all right give to the [ __ ]
this website bro
good job cam you won dude i gotta say if
i
work thank you guys thank you
if i work with the machine i'll be an
unstoppable force man i want to work
against it it can help me and i can help
it and we'll together we'll make the
best images ever i'm afraid i can't do
that disappointing showing by the robot
the thing is the old robot you can type
anything to like for example
love typed man pooping at walmart and
you get some really interesting
potential here
i wrote man peeing in basement on that
last one and it's like super weird
that's nothing
yeah is it safe for work
this is the quartering when he needs to
pee look how creepy that is
like why is this dude in a wheelchair
or is he on the phone okay whatever i'm
i'm out this robot is [ __ ] bro
housewife's time
how's my time [ __ ] that took a lot out
of me
[Laughter]
all right you want to talk about
housewives you go ahead hilah refresh
yourself
yeah
take the lead um well i didn't know that
i was taking the lead on anything
okay
um do i need to open up the document
so jennifer shaw jen shaw yeah i've got
it right here okay i just don't have it
open jen shaw from the housewives of
salt lake city which is our favorite one
yeah
um she has pleaded guilty and we've
talked about it before
she was like arrested on the show while
recording the show
she was what she was so they were about
to go on a girl's ship
and the fbi storms the van
and goes where's jen shaw also it was
super crazy because she all of a sudden
gets a call and then she tells the other
lady next to her can you take off my mic
and then she goes outside to talk on the
phone then she comes back and she's like
my husband is in the hospital i have to
go and totally made up this whole crazy
thing about how he's in the hospital in
a bad condition and she has to go check
on him she got a tip and john yeah the
police then she drives away
and then they arrested her
they found like i think she was driving
somewhere home or something like that
and they arrested her
and that was all during recording the
show it was crazy so there was a whole
season went down and she's like this is
[ __ ] i'm innocent i know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about
she was charged for wiring wire fraud
and money laundering i'm telling you the
show is so insane
and like what's crazy is there was like
an arc of like when it first happened
everybody kind of felt like oh yeah it
was always suspicious how she had so
much money and like so everybody was
kind of like immediately believing it
and not sure how to be friends with her
and then um
it goes on to the next season and she's
back on the show
and then everybody is back to being
friends with her and she goes on like
oh i'm the victim and
i'm totally innocent i would never do
something this i would never hurt
victims and like i cried
you guys know me how dare you question
me
you know i would never she had to
downsize her house and she was
complaining about how she had to pay her
lawyers mailing to dollar should offend
her she brings up race too a lot like
she's um
she's not she's not black her husband is
black and she's
asian right she looks like half a it's
hard to tell what she is because she has
so much plastic surgery but it kind of
feels like she tries to play a little
bit of a race card
she keeps calling herself a color person
of color she's tongan and hawaii yeah
so but
let me show you a picture of her but
yeah i thought it was interesting she
goes you only say that because i'm a
person of color yeah
and i'm like well
i mean this is what she looks like
i don't know if i i'm not the person of
the poc police
but like her race is plastic surgery
when you get this muscle extra surgery
everyone starts looking the same and i
mean not to take anything away from her
experience as that it's just that it was
weird how she kept bringing it up the
whole season because it's kind of like
well you're being accused of like
frauding people and scamming people it's
something that she did do and you did do
yeah so but the whole time she was like
crying and she's like how dare you
question me you know me i would never do
that so she just now pleaded guilty
oh and this is a crazy detail she had
her mom somebody in the chat reminds us
of it she had her mom liquidate her
retirement
for her defense because she had to give
the lawyer like a million dollars took
money from her mom yes
retirement money that's like literally
what she robbed old people about exactly
but well so here's the detail she had
her mom liquidate her retirement for her
but she was sentenced to
so she took a plea deal she got 14 years
in prison
and she has to pay victims back 9.5
million dollars and she had to forfeit
6.5 million dollars so she has money
that she needs to give back and she had
her mom liquidate she loves ripping off
old people what she was doing she says
in her statement i take full
responsibility for my actions i knew
this was wrong i knew many people were
harmed and i'm so sorry [ __ ] spent a
whole [ __ ] season crying about how
she would never do this
she and that she told the judge she
would not even appeal
if she was sentenced to 168 months or
less that's over 10 years
yeah that just tells you they have so
much evidence on her that she has to try
to get a deal with them her lawyer was
like dude
you're [ __ ] and she's still on the
show right now
so the last season ended with her just
being like i'm totally innocent and and
i think it was before like any trial
happened or so it was just kind of like
she's free and walking around and we
don't know what's gonna happen so now
this happened in between seasons
but i think the next season right now i
think that i read that the next season
is they finished filming right before
this happens yes
it's gonna be so [ __ ] wonderful i
wish that they didn't stop
next season they're gonna get like uh
visits they're gonna be oh my god the
call
gentiles in jail it's probably gonna
come out after like the i think right
now we have the beverly hills
running so it's probably gonna come out
after that because i think they kind of
like stacked them dude every show sucks
compared to salt lake yes
but so her crime was like super evil bro
she was generating leads of mostly
elderly people
and working with people who were calling
them and running scams on the old people
and essentially stealing their money she
stole tens of millions of people from
old people their retirement fund and
then she stole money from her own mom's
retirement fund when she knew her ass
was guilty let's [ __ ] go again shaw
and she said one more time and she was
like more for the road baby so she would
flaunt her wealth like beyond all the
other people on the show so it's crazy
to see her now and all these like gucci
track suits every day and it's like this
you're paying for it with old people's
money that you stole from them that they
don't have now it's crazy these women
are also trashy one of the other people
who's on housewives
she's this lady who has like a cult like
a cult like literally a mormon christian
cult like it's [ __ ] creepy bro
and um
and then also obviously erica jane her
husband went to jail for stealing money
from from his clients dude these women
are [ __ ] trashy but the funniest part
is like what ela touched on
is when she got arrested all the girls
are like she's super rich and we have no
idea what she does yeah she makes her
money yeah
but then they very quickly let it go and
they're like well she's in a sense so
innocent until proven guilty kind of
thing
oh my god it's so good
i don't know how they're gonna
react to this now because they've all
been like back to being best friends
with her they'll just blame her they'll
say uh we didn't no we trusted her yeah
do you think they'll film the trial
i don't think it's going to be much of a
trial to be honest it's just synthetic
right
she already pleaded guilty
so there you have it um [ __ ] awesome
so there you go is that everything you
wanted to get out
well i'm i'm dying for this next season
to start of salt lake city
yeah
in the meantime we're watching the
current season of beverly hills
housewives it's really
i'm so over them because they like they
just feel like they think they're better
than
the show at this point
and so they're just all kind of being
super fake
boring but we're definitely tim sutton
for anybody that's watching
so obviously your israeli ela
and you know how hard it's been to
mend the divide
uh in that part of the land okay the
sunni and shia muslims for example abi
you know something about this right yeah
so what is going on with the sunni and
shia because jordan peterson has put out
a video he is actually has a solution
for this like millennial old violent
divide yeah honestly i wouldn't even
know where to begin it's one of the
oldest uh
conflicts in history right on sunday
muslims
um
personally i don't even like to claim
what sect i am because i don't believe
in the division
but uh
oddly enough after hearing jordan
peterson i think he may have solved it
yes so it's the sunnis the sunnis are
the ones that are right
the sunnis are right no i was i'm
kidding
i'm going to say i'm shia bro
yeah but no jordan peterson he's
actually delving into um political
science and uh diplomacy so this is
great the guy's a great thinker
one of the most brilliant minds here at
ticolison muslims
reach across the sectarian divide
shiites
find a sunni pen pal
communicate with someone on the other
side sunnis do the same
and then
maybe reach out tentatively
to a christian or even heaven forbid
a jew
because perhaps it is time
yo zach you gotta grab that sound bite
heaven forbid a jew jews
jews
so there it is get a pen pal folks do
you know do you i mean yeah i found the
sunni guy in tik tok we're talking about
obi-wan right now it's actually yeah
it's working
specifically
make sure that that you get a jewish pen
pal as well god forbid yeah what means
my jewish pen pal
he's so inside his brain is rotting
it feels like i'm listening to a rotting
brain like
over week by week what i hear it gets
dumber and dumber and worse and worse my
favorite is just how he he delivers it
with such conviction yeah
he's like if you all just listen to me
muslims muslims reach across listen up
play this from every moss speaker across
the land
right
listen up muslims
get yourself a sunni pen pal
god forbid a jew
write each other
and listen up bucko
that's the sectarian divide
shiites
find a sunni pen pal oh communicate with
someone on the other side sunnis do the
same
and then this is your homework for the
week it back to me
love that
he was hard to follow but at the end of
the video he sort of suggested uh
someone creating a platform to make that
possible and he will endorse it
wow he is such a [ __ ] over inflated
stuff a platform that's what it seemed
like to me it's hard for me to follow up
with like a social media player i don't
know he didn't say platform i forget i
need to post i haven't posted in two
weeks i will promote die in here
if i promote it everyone will [ __ ]
use it
jordan peterson
[Laughter]
andrew tate as you guys know cobra the
human trafficker as we like to call him
is making his rounds on the internet in
a big way he was on hayden ross he was
on uh
xqc
and he's been exposed to millions
millions do they all know about him and
what or they just ignore all that stuff
dude i don't think these people care
they're just like oh this is a hot guest
right yeah but i think they don't really
know but how can they not know if
they're you have to do some preparation
for a guest interview if you type andrew
tate
like and try to look up anything about
him the first thing you're going to see
is a video of him beating the [ __ ] out
of a woman and being arrested very
recently for human trafficking and
kidnapping okay
this is this is who we're dealing with
if i could just uh talk about the dave
pornoy situation uh he
explains early in the podcast that josh
was the one who really wanted to bring
on
uh cobra tate
just to get that out josh a little piece
of [ __ ]
so dave is still in the running for
besties is that what you're saying i'm
just trying to keep david
okay josh is what 17.
probably like 20. he is 20. yeah
but anyway apparently i think dave at
least challenged him a bit but in my
opinion it's like you know and people
say that about xqc he challenged him but
it's like
his argument is so bad faith and so
nonsense it's like challenging it's like
having an argument with a nazi about why
they shouldn't exterminate all jews
right
engaging in the conversation is valid
it's giving validity to it even if
you're disagreeing because it's it's so
insane
that
it shouldn't be even engaged with
seriously
because the net positive for all this
for cobra tate is just going to be that
he gets more fans even if 90 of people
thinks he's crazy yeah
i would say xqc was pushing back more
than the others i mean i agree with you
that they shouldn't platform at all but
the xqc he has like literally young men
this is his target demo if 10 of his
audience were like
this guy's dope that's a net loss for
humanity
some people just are not [ __ ]
worth talking to genuinely
you know what what do you say to a nazi
how do you convince a nazi not to kill
jews you'll be like now do you realize
that uh you're killing people and that's
bad it's like okay and even more
specifically the jews yeah
anyway here's a little clip from dave
pogue pork boy like you say a lot of
stuff about women like that they're your
property
that's not what i said i was talking
about only fans company when that was
question was asked but i said that if a
woman is going out with a man she
belongs to that man that's his woman so
she wants to do only fan she owes him
some money because she's his yes you
think well that's crazy you think it's
crazy so you think that a man going out
with a girl that that's just your
property
there can't be an equal relationship
that one was nuts that one was nice
it goes crazy
no that that one you can if i understood
what you said that if a guy and a girl
is dating and a girl does only fans she
owes him a cut no 100
100 he is his girl
but what does that have doing because
she's his
yeah so that's why so that is you saying
that women are your property this is
this is the part where it is
nazis he's not the kid
yeah he it's not a sane thing he's
saying yeah and you're not gonna talk
reason to him you're trying to convince
him of something that's that's utterly
nuts on its face you know what i mean
yeah it's not it's like you're putting
this guy he's entertaining and he's
funny and he's crazy
but he's serious and that's what's so
[ __ ] up dude he's
he's serious about what he's saying
so like
yeah it's entertaining because he's so
nuts but it's actually just
really [ __ ] up to even platform this
guy at all
it's definitely a net
l for the world i'd actually like to see
what xqc challenged him on i don't think
we ever watched that did we love he he
shall share everything he said pretty
much uh
like the typical alpha stuff i mean i
guess his uh top clips would be hey if
you can find some that'd be cool i'm
gonna keep watching this clip and let me
know if you find anything interesting
about that it's not about being property
it's about the fact that she belongs to
him and the intimate parts of her body
belong to him because they're in a
relationship
parts of her body so so it's reverse uh
male porn star owes the woman
i don't know because i think the women
belong to the man i think the woman's
that's inherently where you get called
sexist no it's not well you can you can
call me sexist if you want but if you
look at marriage it's the bride's father
who gives her away it's not the groom's
father no tradition
i gotta i gotta get this
man
yeah no but i gotta guess as somebody
who's multicultural and everything that
that certainly is a tradition that does
not apply everywhere
the woman has always given over to the
man read read the bible read the quran
you can go to the walking dead
no chance there's definitely there's
like african cultures where they don't
do that i'm sure there are some obscure
tribes somewhere i mean i can't say i'm
a professional you you get it you seem
like you've got a smart guy
you seem like a smart guy you're saying
uh a woman is the property of a man
about it
what's
i don't think you're a chauvinist i just
want to be clear right but um so he goes
yeah no i'm not a chauvinist but anyway
like i'm down for women empowerment they
can do only fans they just have to give
me the money
because that's women are
he has a [ __ ] sweatshop
of human trafficked women he forces into
webcam slavery
like yeah he keeps like denying this
stuff but then he's like i'm not saying
that they're property i'm just saying
that i own them and i have a financial
stake in them yeah that's property yeah
you're describing property also if you
consider what we talked about on
wednesday he used to have on his pickup
site an anecdote about how he's right
here yeah i've been running a webcam
studio for nearly a decade i've had over
75 girls work for me and my business
model is different than 99 of webcam
owners over 50 percent of my employees
were actually my girlfriend at the time
right and all of my girlfriends none of
them were in the adult industry before
they met me right so this is something
he's proud of go down what my job was to
make women fall in love with me
literally that was my job my job was to
meet a girl
go on a few dates sleep with her test if
she's quality get her to fall in love
with me to what where she do anything i
say and then get her on a webcam so we
become rich together whether you agree
or disagree with what i did with their
loyalty submission and love for me
doesn't matter you cannot reject the
reject the results
and the results are simple my girls
my girlfriends would do more for me than
99.9 of men's wives would do for them
cool
pictures of like their tattooing his
name on that yeah but you know and then
you take him how do you have this as an
admission
he
you'll notice this is on the way back
yeah because he has removed all of this
because he is basically just admitting
to no because but it was still up not
that far not that long like a month or
two
this is from last summer but i i think
it was up until like the end of the year
yeah
because he's getting so much mainstream
exposure he realized that he stands to
make a lot more money
if he's not admitting openly to human
trafficking people which is what he does
that's how he got rich right and he's
admitted even though he constantly says
he doesn't care about being canceled and
he's above all of that and he's outside
of the matrix or whatever but meanwhile
he's scrubbing all of this from the
internet yeah
i mean he he seriously like should be in
prison probably he absolutely should be
in prison and he just got raided i think
and he's he lives in romania because
it's corrupt as [ __ ] he literally said i
moved here because the rape laws are
last yeah and you know he probably pays
people off and they don't [ __ ] with him
but the american embassy literally was
like yo someone there has been sex
trafficked and kidnapped you need to go
rescue them and the police went in and
rescued them and then let the guys go
telling you there's a point in this
podcast where he says he makes enough
money to be above the law where he lives
yeah
exactly that's what it is
you know
yep
so like it's not cute or funny or
interesting or cool this guy's a [ __ ]
main like a dangerous criminal
um that is actively harming people and a
whole and any man who listens and
and believes anything he says is [ __ ]
for life i mean let's be honest
belong to the man it doesn't mean
they're a pure property without emotion
that means they're believing they're
given to the man they take the man's
name
it's the guy's parts you're like if
she's on only fans the guy owns those
parts so he gets a cut well those parts
are intimate right that's the whole
point of her being his yeah but you
didn't do reverse when i said if a uh
gay if a male porn star
does it he doesn't owe the girl a cut
correct because she because he doesn't
belong to her she still belongs to him
correct so that's the sexist part and
you've also said that that you could you
also said that you could have multiple
partners but a female that was with you
couldn't also have multiple partners
well a woman could say that same thing
if she decided she could say i can sleep
with multiple men but my men can't sleep
with multiple women if she's so choose
we're all free individuals right yeah
but you don't you wouldn't agree if a
woman said that i don't think i i would
personally find that revolting correct
but there are women who find what i say
revolting so you're not telling other
people what to think you're just saying
how you think yeah i mean if i i think
that i mean i can't back him up dave
except he literally sells
like
that that's his whole business is
selling
a you know
tate university or whatever the [ __ ]
yeah telling people how they should
think let's see if they linked it
as part of his uh
are they plug them in the description
yeah
there's a user
who's just gifted subs and his name or
her name is
no he didn't
tate is my property
oh you just got owned [ __ ]
that's uh that's our saudi prince oh
that's our saudi prince she's gifted 50
subs tate is my property
i was telling you about you our saudi
prince about how he's always going nuts
every time how do you know or what he's
not a saudi prince this is a joke okay
but he's donated like hundreds
maybe a thousand subs i don't know at
this point probably getting close to a
thousand yeah maybe five hundred i don't
know
i've made it in person every time yeah
i've actually made contact with this
person now okay yeah we got we learned a
little bit about him
i'll say one thing that we learned
that's interesting in other countries
the memberships
are much cheaper
um
i see that's part of that's part of it
that said they're still spending a
substantial amount of money supporting
the show and we super duper appreciate
that but is that like a money hack if he
buys the free money hack that's right
right factory buys 50 subs and they go
to americans yeah
i don't know how does that work i don't
know how youtube treats it uh yeah
that's a good question
someone said their dog struggles with a
prolapse
looked like a donut oh no
shout out kaylee webb would tuck that
back in there girl what do we do about
it there's nothing having to do about it
does anybody know how does a poor doggie
get a pro left yeah
tuck that back right in there bye
give a man is uh
sexual is not sexually exclusive it's
not the same as a woman is because with
a woman you have the paternity issue
with a man you don't have a paternity
issue if i have three girlfriends and
they all get pregnant we know who the
mother and who the father is if you have
one woman and three men you don't know
who even the parents are if she got
pregnant so it's a whole big issue right
science can still be trying to fix it
definitely
dna tests are pretty accessible nowadays
of course yeah that's exactly it so i
said science can step in and fix it but
that doesn't mean it's not haram and
against the will of god look read them
now he's concerned about haram
does that check out but anyway he's a
[ __ ] lunatic and i wish people would
stop having him on the goddamn show he
followed him
peterson
right and let's not forget
that cobra the human trafficker was
dating
jordan peterson's daughter their friends
was crazy she said nice things about him
she said he's a good guy he's a good guy
how [ __ ] nuts is that bro
holy
god i heard her describing her time
i wasn't sure who he was at the time
when i was listening to that old podcast
and she made it sound like you know he
was aladdin taking her on a magic carpet
ride i had no idea who he was so it's
funny to now in retrospect know who he
is yep a whole new world let me show you
my webcams
here's your changed only or your chain
don't leave the room
show them your titties give the money to
me
a whole new world with me
i can hide you from the world oh take
you away from your parents from your
parents
the fbi is looking for you
don't tell the embassy that you have
been human trafficked by me
unbelievable crimes
uh love and
uh ab
uh linked some of these xqc clips yeah
if you're interested in any of these
yeah here's xqc had him on the day
before and had and every time this guy
on he pulls crazy numbers like hundreds
of thousands of people watching live on
twitch
they didn't hit 100k this time though
okay that aiden ross would have like 230
000 i didn't under even understand like
what the [ __ ] was going on
but he'll see xqc makes an argument
against gender jokes from destiny
wait that doesn't say i don't understand
everything that said
there's one here that says xqc made tate
leave the discord call that i'm kind of
curious
he made he made him rage quit at one
point oh wait he's not even in this clip
is that is that
i i've thought after destiny about this
and he had a very good point about this
okay i'll tell you why this [ __ ] works
like that okay i've speak about this
before and i said it once i'll say it
again okay the pro the problem with
these things okay is it is is that is
that uh when you have we have uh people
that are that are literally anti-woman
or anti-whatever race right aidan ross
not even listening bro he just took a
bug out and wiped it on his desk he's
constantly like he's always yeah i've
watched a few different clips and he's
he has his finger in his nose for like
three out of he
why the [ __ ] do people watch him
like dude had 230 000 people watching
when he talked to cobra tate
look at this when you have
you know what he's doing he's saving it
to eat it later
got a collection going
whatever right and you make certain
statements right that you know somehow
or intricate and funny in a way then you
have to explain right and you think that
you're saying oh dude woman can't drive
huh chad says it
people say
but you know for a fact a decent portion
of people out there are like
yeah
[ __ ] the cage by [ __ ] women
but he's still hosting him so i think
he's still
putting entertaining people
trying to do a good show and pull
numbers over
because he just acknowledged there's
going to be a certain amount of people
that it resonates with
no matter who's talking to him
where's the one where let's see
excuse me
second to last second to last one
fails that's my personal experience you
can't give a chat holy oh wait no no
the next
you just gotta link me because it's
impossible to tell one from the other
yeah fails that's my personal experience
you can't come along and tell me that's
not true so and i don't know
the next time we have a problem with
science or some [ __ ] or physics why why
go to the internet or talk some experts
let's go with ask kate's experience on
it and we'll have the answer to it right
you [ __ ] sorry
sorry no answers now i just got i got
unhinged
i didn't understand the context at all
yeah but um
if you guys want me to watch one just
the last one in the discord if you just
open that right there okay
okay
let me know but to sit here and talk to
a man who thinks he can send his chick
downstairs to [ __ ] engaged bar men i
know i'm wasting my hair okay okay
argument was a bad argument i thought it
was the bear argument i agree with the
bear comes out train wrecks there
you see
the whole gang is here yeah
that's okay
these are all the gamblers what love
uh maybe i have a little bit different
opinion than you but i think xqc and
train wrecks have like a very very young
fan bases and them coming out and really
arguing and going against this i think
has an in my opinion a net positive
because i think andrew tate is so big
already if you just look at tick-tock
his tick tock's blowing up all the time
like has multiple millions of views i
think it's good to have voices talking
against him
uh at in any context i i see what you're
saying
i'm kind of torn because i've heard i've
seen xqc have really good takes about
sexism and stuff like that
but you can talk about him without
having him on the show so i don't know
but i think we're just too far gone and
tate is here and he's like massive and
at this point anyone who goes against
him that has young fan bases is positive
uh but i also understand you're
i mean it's better it's much better for
xqc the way he's talking to him than
like adam ross who's just like oh
absolutely platform just being like yeah
go ahead do your thing buddy but
challenging them yeah and arguing with
them and telling them about it you see
on train wrecks after the stream also
like spent a couple minutes reflecting
and really
like speaking super good facts like the
second to last clip uh just above the
one that you clicked uh before can you
reset it because that one didn't make it
i clicked it it was like five seconds
yeah
again
and you save the chick she runs but in
the house argument it was just a bad
argument no but dude xqc disagree with
that you're agreeing but he didn't agree
with that yeah the bear argument is
right but the house argument was wrong
the bear argued that i don't know none
of these clips make any sense
i need a little curating here
i can
like there's no context at all to any of
these
you know i found out that uh tate
doesn't even have a tick tock today all
those tick tocks you see are just people
uh making fake pages for him no he does
and he lies about or he lies about it
but yeah they're definitely him just
like he doesn't have a twitter he has a
twitter oh yeah
it's very clearly him on portnoy's
podcast he said instagram and twitter
but because he's banned on twitter he
gets banned off of these platforms and
then you know he does the keemstar move
where it's it's somebody else yeah or he
pays someone i love just link it dude
yes i click these i click these and it's
always a different one it's the last one
i linked
all right
so this is about greek's behavior
i agree with you i think there's a lot
of deliberate stuff and honestly i'm
gonna what does this have to do with
anything greek god x
what what's the context well i was i was
talking about how they reflected
afterwards they were talking and i
thought they brought up a good point
here
down i agree with you i think there's a
lot of deliberate stuff and honestly i'm
at a point right now where
watching greek i would actually use
greek as an example i i actually i
started this i started today on aidan's
uh podcast or whatever that was i
started thinking
greek's trolling that's how i've always
been
but i'm beginning to realize
he may not be
and the the irresponsible factor that
we're referring to right now as a result
i think is greek hey i mean he's
maximizing that i mean he's maxing it
out he's busting and we're talking about
greek god it's a different it's a
different thing
but yeah greek god x is a [ __ ] we
talked about him briefly okay anyway
it's kind of hard to follow all these
links so i'm just gonna move on but uh
that's my opinion on uh cobra tate
i didn't really see any good clips of
xqc challenging him
i don't think there really were any yeah
and that's why we i mean i made the call
to not even include this [ __ ] because
it it's just kind of
chaotic nightmare like everything that
he does that's true yeah so here's the
one xqc may take leave the discord call
let's see we watch that we watch this we
already watched that one let's just move
on oh we did this conversation is not
going away okay there you go thank you
did you guys know that 50 cent is
linking up with cab cab
[Music]
for a new why is kavkav still trying to
make movies bro it's done you're done
it's not happening bro stop trying to
live relive the best
drive angry
50 cent
is uh making a horror film
with
ryan cavanaugh
and bryce hall will be starring in it no
[ __ ] shot yeah
oh
oh really yeah
what
there was an interesting theory floating
around the office i don't know if
someone wants to claim it but someone
thought maybe the movie is going to be a
big goof on you
oh well i just i didn't think that the
entire it was me and i didn't think it
was going to be all about you but
because ryan's in it and it's about
if you read the description of that
ryan's in it or i'm sorry he's producing
it yeah the description of the movie is
like the dark side of social media
influencer world blah blah blah oh yeah
there's gonna be an ethan character yeah
that's for sure yeah
well that's awesome then i'm excited to
watch it
but i think i'm the only one
i'm excited
dude what the [ __ ] bryce hall and ryan
kavanagh this is awesome
oh my god
thank you
this film is bursting with mavericks of
energy entertainment
[Laughter]
what
mavericks this is a quote of kavanaugh
many of them spanning multiple genres
and platforms said kavanaugh
from a global rap and hip-hop music icon
to a businessman actor writer and
producer if anyone knows a thing or two
about breaking the boundaries it's 50
cent
i'm honored to work along with him as we
watch bryce do the same with his career
oh [ __ ] this is going to be such a
[ __ ] flop
thank you
whoa
this is so interesting
there you have it
thank you the dark side of social media
produced by ryan kavanagh
it's just about someone editing his
wikipedia page exactly
he wakes up in a sweat and it's just his
wikipedia page is all [ __ ] up
groundhog day
oh who's who who are they casting for
ethan
i don't know
go to hell
i hope 50 cent is cast 50 cent as ethan
he would probably try to cast him to
look like me right um yeah
hannah stocking and charlie demilio are
supposed to be in it as well oh god this
is a recipe from that so good
we should keep oh sorry you should ask
if you could be in it i was about to say
keep an eye on the casting calls for
this film and if there's something for a
30-something uh
jewish man hey
let's make a self too yeah let's send in
an audition tape oh [ __ ]
that'd be so funny so good
the movie is called skill house
and it's about how far people will go to
attain fame on social media
starring the people who sold their soul
for social media like priced off right
i can't believe it's taking place at the
sway house
that's amazing somebody said seth rogen
is ethan klein
let's see that's too flattering let's do
flattering yeah
i don't think i could kill it i would
cast seth rogen no i'm saying i think
it's
an ethan i i agree but if he's trying to
make me look bad
um yeah
you're better looking to seth rogen
thank you but that's not the point i'm
trying to make but yeah
i accept that
anyway i don't know what to say that's
about it eh
we've got some other stuff here and
there but you know whatever
it's been three hours yeah it's been
three hours since you looked at me
take corporate stealing my daughter
locked up in a little room got the
webcam and now was it a sorry
people saying danny devito
oh
shrek is ethan oh now we're talking
danny devito i i would be like a a
penguin-esque villain in his movie
that's awesome
i'm
sorry somebody uh used their membership
super chat
to say my great grandma's uterus
prolapsed just in case you were looking
for another thing to be afraid of
did someone google um how i know lady
well he asks people to do the tick tock
thing in his uh high school thing or
whatever
what
he asks he asks his fans to do like
tick-tock edits of him oh as part of his
program yeah i heard someone say oh my
god so you pay this guy to tell you
how to be a man or whatever and he's
like all right step one start doing free
social media work for me start posting
andrew tate memes
non-stop all over the internet that is
pretty alpha wow
uh are you being olivia
you guys see any prolapse
yeah we just look back on their faces
i'm just not looking at it it looks
pretty much the same but because i know
what it is it hurts a little bit more
seeing it this time there you go here
look at this it's a it's a
send me on discord no genital reading is
exposed dimly
i want to know what an old lady's
prolapse looks like why
well if they saw it i want to see it
oh god
yep oh [ __ ] the title of the link av
just sent me oh my what
87 year old woman had to undergo a
vaginal prolapse repair
oh
dude what the [ __ ] far away from your
side i wonder how does that happen
how does a vagina prolapse
[Music]
sex
okay yeah jordan nailed it on that one
all right all right i'm tired it's been
a fun time it's been a controversial
time it's been uh
been a lot of ends a lot of outs cameron
defeated the machine yep
yo
ela what do you think about triller's
new um podcast
[Laughter]
right but you got to get paid boy i get
it you're on that paper chase
you know
oh um powerhouse this is just a little
aside
but
way earlier in the show we had already
moved on from the conversation so i
didn't bring it up but i just want to
show you this is a local
ambulance chasing lawyer
uh from one from the hometown of one of
our fans
yeah what's up with your forehead though
look at his hairline dude look at this
zoom in on that it's almost down to his
[ __ ] eyebrow wait that's not
photoshopped that's not an ai generator
no apparently it bill definitely i need
more photos because that [ __ ] looks
sketchy bro yeah
it's like
bill barr i'm not buying that hairline
dude
also it's low-res like who you falling
man he's got the smallest forehead of
anyone that's ever lived there's his
website all right yeah bro that
picture's [ __ ] up
why are you using that photo
that looks like a dolly image generation
totally
the [ __ ]
i need more photos of you buddy
bill barr
just type william l bar law
because bill barr the
former attorney general it's kind of
hard to get stuff
he shares a name with a very prominent
lawyer take his number off screen tim
sorry
anyway
well bill if you're watching can we see
you get some more photos of your
hairline because we're working on a
hairline website
you're a contender a strong contender
there yes no
he has no forehead he's a one head it's
gone it's a two hand
i mean between the eyebrows and the
hairline there's nothing left there's no
skin left right
[Laughter]
someone says google theresa
guys
real housewife of new jersey yeah you
know you see that she's they say she has
no she's got a little forehead you see
theresa what
just look up theresa knew how uh
new jersey
new jersey
thank you to everyone who's
participating in the teddy fresh sale i
see a lot of people saying
um
they're getting some teddy fresh for the
phone which is awesome oh wow is she not
wearing a wig though
um no i don't think so
wait she went to prison right she did
another prison wasn't that hurt i think
i heard about that yeah it was a tax
evasion or something yeah
god these women are insane or maybe it
was her husband it was her and her
husband they both went to jail not at
the same time because i at something
with the kids or something like that
yeah you can hear separate sentences
yeah so so one went i think she did
first and then the husband went or the
husband got a little longer than her
yeah
and all that's just oh that's what it
says released from prison bro
dude it's crazy how many housewives have
gone to prison like there's like five
like five that's nuts and all of them
are like tax fraud or [ __ ] stealing
money
dude
so awesome
oh so are we doing tiptoes this weekend
or
next weekend what do we decide i mean
that's ultimately up to you because you
guys
sacrificed your weekend last weekend
although next weekend we're actually
getting dinner with bobby lee i did his
podcast yesterday it was totally off the
rails yeah
i bet
do you know when it's coming out no clue
they're pretty quick
are they yeah it should come out like
this weekend or maybe monday or
something like that
they usually turn them around so she was
so sorry what is the tiptoes i wasn't
following
it's gary oldman's role of a lifetime
well we got to plan for that with the
kids yeah because right now the thing is
my mom can't watch the kids because
they're still coveted positive
oh
right she was gonna come watch theodore
this weekend but he's still positive and
she's compromised we gotta wait the ten
days so yeah it's almost ten days
so maybe next weekend not this week and
then not this weekend
that's uh
my
yeah it is my birthday weekend so it
could be a little short oh
dad's birthday party yeah next weekend
somewhere for your week for your
birthday that sounds great well let's
talk about all right there's some other
stuff with that so you don't want a
doctor's birthday party
i'm kidding all right well then i just
don't want you to come yeah thank you
thank you thank you
uh we'll see you on monday have a good
weekend it's friday baby
[ __ ] baby [ __ ]
oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] in my dick [ __ ] my dick [ __ ]
all right guys all right see you next
week have a great weekend bye y'all for
watching
you'll see the best podcast in the world
take it from me jc over chair hp baby we
podcast now
you're watching h to the three three
three three you're watching h to the
three three three three
why are you so cute when you talk [ __ ]
you're wet tonight